Und ah ja jetzt wollte gerade sagen irgendwie ist mein kabel nicht richtig drin gewesen
so jetzt geht's aber also
Ich war auch zwei minuten nicht da aber ich habe gerade reingeschwätzt und habe festgestellt es kommt nichts raus
aber ich merke das ja relativ schnell weil
Ich spiele ja teile von dem
Aber irgendwie stimmt trotzdem noch was nicht oder
warte mal
Ich muss mich gerade mal kurz ja ja skip
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla ist alles gut ok mal kurz gucken check
Checken aber kabel sieht jetzt okay aus
Ja weil ich spiele ja teile von dem was ich sage wieder ein und wenn ich halt ins mikrofon rede und gar nichts höre dann
Heißt was in der regel ist es irgendwie kaputt
So
Ein bisschen was entspannteres man
Exzellent
Moin Moin, Dan2Dev, dankeschön für den Sub, dazu kann ich nur sagen das ist extrem
Chat, ich war jetzt paar tage nicht on, was heißt gar so viel war es ja gar nicht
Ich glaube nur gestern und vorgestern war ich nicht on
Sonst war ich fast jeden tag da letzte woche für meine verhältnisse auch schon relativ viel
Aber ich muss mal wieder ein youtube video aufnehmen das fast schon monat her oder irgendwie 23 tage oder so her
Einmal wieder zeit wobei das aktuelle video ganz gut ankommt das hat slow slow gestartet
Aber ist jetzt richtig richtig hoch gegangen hier ich meine muss ich mal angucken
Youtube
Das wollten gar nicht so viele leute gucken am anfang haben wir nur 20k leute initial geguckt was nicht sonderlich viel ist
aber
Dann hat sich der youtube algorithmus gedacht aha
Das ist ein thema
Das möchten ganz viele leute sehen
Und jetzt hat sie noch 25k dazu gekriegt in zwei wochen
Also das doppelte an mehr als das doppelte an views gekriegt
Durch youtube und das ist so ein typisches video ich muss mal gerade in die stats gucken
Das steigt auch über die nächsten jahre noch weiter mich würde nicht wundern wenn das 60 70k bald hat
in ein zwei monaten
Es gibt so ein paar es gibt so ein paar videos die werden sowieso dauerbrenner mäßig einsortiert im youtube algorithmus weil das ist ja auch
Es ist ja auch ein sehr allgemeines thema was irgendwie potenziell
Jeden interessieren kann der sich das auch schon mal gefragt hat
Aber nicht teilzeit arbeiten soll
Und da kommen jetzt halt nicht nur zwang da kommt jetzt nicht nur die die eh schon subscribed haben bei mir
Sondern alle mögliche die das vielleicht auch mal in die suche eingeben
Sieht man auch sieht man auch an den videoempfehlungen da ist alles mögliche dabei
So gut so gut wie kein gaming
Also sonntags ist glaube ich eines der wenigen termine die haben wir jetzt die letzten drei vier jahre
konstant konstant durchgehalten ich glaube
Ich überlege kann ich glaube die einzigen wahle wo es kein sonntag stream gegeben hat also wo ich corona hatte
Gab es glaube ich mal kein sonntag eine woche gab es glaube ich kein gesondert oder zwei wochen weiß ich genau ich glaube eine woche
also eine woche auf jeden fall
Gab es keinen sonntag stream
Bestimmt noch eins zweimal aber aber in der summe so gut wie gar nicht also
glaube
Witz kann man darauf klicken
kann man
Jetzt müssen wir das ganze bloß noch sortieren nach sonntags
Streams ist das ist das die uhrzeit hier in dem kästchen
Oder wie
Oder was sagt was sagt einem das kästchen hier
Ach nee das ist die tage wie es im monat sich verteilt ach so
Ich bin doch relativ
Ich bin doch relativ oft an oder
Guckt euch das mal an
Kann man nichts sagen oder
Also ich meine für das dass ich das nur nebenbei mache
hallo again minus 1
Das wird sein
Ach so was ich eigentlich gucken wollte ob ich sonntags immer und bin ja guck mal
Sonntag durchgehend hier hatte ich also irgendwann im august letztes jahr so in dem drehraum hatte ich corona hier
Hier war corona vielleicht war hier auch noch weil
Nee das ist zu lang
Also hier hatte ich mal drei sonntage wo wir nicht gestreamt haben
da da und da
Aber ansonsten okay hier auch noch mal
Ach ja wisst ihr ich weiß was hier war also hier war auf jeden fall corona
Und hier
Hier
Das ist ja nur ein monat dazwischen also hier war lebensmittel vergiftung
Sein erfolgreichster stream war die apple präsentation wo sie dich abgemahnt haben
Heißt es man sollte mehr illegale sachen machen auf twitch weil die erfolgreich sind
Nee das dass das hier war das hier war lebensmittel vergiftung
Ich habe mir vor ja gut vor 2020 rum wird das gewesen sein
Habe ich mir ein also ich gehe ganz stark davon aus dass es dass es daran lag ja
Ich habe mir einen rahm schnitzel bestellt bei einem liefer service
Also da ist halt so ganz viel auf auf so sahne soße mäßig basiert ist das
Da habe ich danach nach ein paar tagen habe ich gemerkt alle du musst ja irgendwie jetzt alle alle 20 minuten aufs klo
Und hast irgendwie jetzt schon seit zwei wochen dünnschiss irgendwie stimmt irgendwas stimmt da nicht
Und da kam raus am ende
dass ich ein
Virus aus dem essen mir eingefangen habe und zwar wie ist das den
Kampelob
oder so was
genau
wikipedia
nee
doch genau das
Ja
Also dass dass das teil das teil hatte ich
Und da steht auch dass es dass es von allein wieder weg geht in
Überwiegend teil der fälle das ding ist nur die
Das ding war nur die also ich habe das zu zu 95 prozent habe ich das von diesem ein liefer service
Ich habe da nämlich auch mal geguckt es gibt ja mittlerweile so eine
Zeit jetzt nicht welcher das war es gibt so eine genau so eine offizielle plattform wo man sich angucken kann wo es
Hygienemängel gibt und der laden wo ich das bestellt habe wo ich das höchstwahrscheinlich herbekommen hat hat ohne scheiß drei seiten voll dort gehabt
Auf der auf diesem auf dieser seite von weiß ich ob es vom gesundheitsamt ist oder so
der musste sogar schon mal die küche sanieren und so was weil es im arsch war alles also das
Höchstwahrscheinlich habe ich von da gekriegt ich bestelle natürlich auch seitdem da nicht mehr
Und dass das tolle war auch
ich habe
Ich habe ja beim doktor angerufen und habe gesagt hier ich habe seit seit wochen wochen durchfall und alles
Und
Da hat er schon gesagt ja gut dann nur schreibt mal zwei worte das hat er schon am telefon gesagt so
Und da habe ich gemeint hier was haltet ihr denn davon das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen du bist aber auf der zunge zergehen
Also vielleicht nicht wortwörtlich jetzt nehmen ja das müsste ich mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen
Wie planlos die da wieder gewesen sind ja
und zwar ich habe da angerufen und das und das so sieht es aus und
Soll ich euch nicht mal ich meine seit zwei wochen dass das hört dass das hört ja gar nicht
gar nicht auf
Soll ich euch mal so eine probe vorbeibringen so im glas dass ihr das mal einschickt
und haben sie gemeint so
Ja, also das ist eigentlich keine schlechte idee das könnten wir machen so wo ich mir so denke alter warum muss ich das überhaupt vorschlagen
Hätten die nicht sagen können er um zwei wochen ist aber schon ein stück bringen sie mal ein bisschen was mit
Ne das muss man den vorschlag
Zumindest sonst hätte man das gar nicht gemerkt
Das wurde das wurde dann ins labor eingeschickt und auf einmal habe ich post vom gesundheitsamt bekommen dass ich eine meldepflichtige krankheit
Habt das war die ein also vor corona die einzige meldepflichtige krankheit die ich hatte
Und da stand drinne ich darf nicht mehr arbeiten gehen wenn ich in der gastronomie arbeite
und solche dinger
Das war wirklich
Anstrengend was war es kampello bakter das was wir hier gerade offen hatten auf
Wikipedia
das
Das ist es gewesen da hat bananen helfen auch nichts gebracht an der stelle
Da bringt der bananen bringen dir vielleicht was wenn du was schlechtes gegessen hast oder so
Aber nicht wenn die irgendwie die viren im darm hast die nicht mehr weggehen
ne das war
Es war wirklich im wahrsten sinne des wortes ziemlich ziemlich scheiße
Ja ich glaube das ist der grund warum ich da nicht nicht angewiesen bin sonntags
Hier so in dem dreh dass das war ein lebensmittel vergiftung
Aber davor hatten was mehr oder weniger gut hier war ja hier hier war das ja noch gar nicht
default dass wir sonntags geschrieben haben das hat das alles hier so angefangen dann aufwachen streben
und da auch noch nicht mal
Ja der fragebogen war da auch war da auch dabei ich weiß aber gar nicht mehr wie das genau ausgeschaut hat
Ich ich glaube ich habe sogar reingeschrieben
Dass ich das von dem liefer dass ich das höchstwahrscheinlich von dem liefer service habe vielleicht habe ich ja auch mit dazu beigetragen dass die
Mal überprüft wurden und dann drei seiten eintrag bekommen haben dass bei ihnen alles ziemlich kacke ist
Ziemlich ziemlich dreckig und die muss ja sogar ein paar wochen zumachen aber wahrscheinlich nicht wegen wegen dem was ich hatte zwar auch erst viel später
Vielleicht warten die beim gesundheitsamt auch irgendwie ein bisschen bis ein paar meldungen eingegangen sind und erst dann gucken sie sonst sehr viel zu tun
Die wurde erst behandelt also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere gar nicht
Das hat einfach ein paar wochen gedauert
Und dann ging es wieder weg
Das war aber richtig kacke also das hatte ich auch noch nie geiler anfang vom stream wir reden jetzt erst mal kurz eine stunde über
über dünnschiss aber ne viertelstunde aber
Aber
Das hatte ich auch noch nie und zwar
Das war ja nicht nur durchfall das war ja auch mit fieber und allem also man hat richtig man hat richtig gemerkt dass man dass man
Irgendwas nicht einfach nur ich habe was schlechtes gegessen ist
Und
Man war auch komplett im arsch
Also war so richtig kaputt und und eine sache die hatte ich auch noch nie und zwar
Wenn ich versucht habe aufzustehen und das kam mir öfters mal vor weil man ja ab und zu mal aufs klo musste mit mit
Diesem virus ja wenn ich versucht habe aufzustehen ich weiß nicht ob ihr das kennt könnt ihr mir mal schreiben ob das jemand von euch
schon mal hatte und zwar
Du versuchst aufzustehen und das geht nicht und das liegt nicht daran weil du muskelkrafttechnisch nicht in der lage wärst aufzustehen
Also kann sich nur langsam bewegen aber du stehst auf und während dem aufstehen prozess
Hast du den hast du den eindruck dich zieht was nach unten zurück ganz ganz komisch
Also du versuchst du aufzustehen vom bett du kannst schon aufstehen du kannst das schon überwinden aber du hast du während dem aufstehen denkst
Du so okay ich komme kaum nach oben so als zieht was nach hinten ganz merkwürdig gewesen kommt man echt kaum kommt man kaum aufstehen
Während das hatte ich nicht während corona ich war auch ziemlich im arsch während corona aber da war da habe ich mich einfach nur
Erkältungsmäßig kreislauf ja sowas ja da habe ich mich einfach nur erkältungsmäßig
Krank gefühlt ich hatte auch ordentlich fieber und sowas bei corona ich habe es ja gut ich weiß nicht ob ich sagen würde ich
Jetzt richtig erwischt kann man so nicht sagen weil ich hatte ja keine
Atem lungen sonst was probleme ich hatte bei corona halt die üblichen geschichten
Ich war also mit mich hat schon im vergleich zu manchen die gar nichts merken habe hat es mich schon ziemlich ziemlich mitgenommen also ich hatte
Vor nase laufen halsschmerzen bis fieber alles mögliche und das das ging auch das ging auch eine ganze weile es ging auch
Also richtig so richtig ging es eineinhalb wochen und dann ging es dann hat es bestimmt noch mal 223 wochen gedauert
Bis bis ich wieder bis ich wieder komplett und dann auch nicht hundertprozentig fit also das hat ein bisschen gedauert zumindest
Ich vergesse was ich sagen wollte
Zumindest zumindest hatte ich das bei co bei corona nicht
Aber was ich aber aber was ich genau jetzt weiß ich zwar wieder was ich bei corona hatte
Ja genau es gibt ein paar dies dies dies nicht gemerkt habe also ich habe es auf jeden fall gemerkt
Ich meine ich habe es mir auch ich weiß sogar wo ich mir corona eingefangen habe viele wissen das ja nicht ich habe ich
Weiß es ganz genau wo ich mir corona eingefangen habe
Ich war auf einem iron maiden konzert in frankfurt
Und da schreien und singen so viele leute und das war zwar im stadion was eigentlich ganz gut belüftet ist aber ich habe 100 pro von
dort
Und eventuell auch von der s-bahn fahrt hin und zurück
Da dadurch das war auch kein knackevoll da habe ich mir 100 pro damit mir sehr sehr sicher ich würde es da eingefangen habe
Zumindest eine sache die
Also wie gesagt ich habe es ein bisschen gemerkt ich habe ich habe es nicht total schlimm gehabt also nicht in form von irgendwie
atemprobleme oder sonst was ja
Aber was ich hatte ist und das war auch echt anstrengend
Also neben fieber und nase laufen sowas ich hatte irgendwie übelst hohen ruhepuls in der zeit
Also normalerweise hast du keine ahnung was hast du normalerweise für den ruhepuls wenn im bett liegt 70 oder so
65 70 irgendwie sowas in dem dreh
So und ich habe ich habe da ab und zu mal blutdruck und puls und so gemessen
56 da bist ja schon leistungssportler wenn 56 ruhepuls hast ich glaube ich glaube ja ein ulrich hatte damals als er tour de france gefahren ist
56 ruhepuls ist schon echt schon echt relativ niedrig
also
Also irgendwas um 65 65 70 vielleicht so und zumindest ich hatte dann ruhepuls von 105
Und dementsprechend lag ich im bett
Und ich konnte ich konnte mich nicht richtig ausruhen
Du hast du hast das war ganz ganz merkwürdig du hast versucht zu schlafen ja
Aber du bist nicht so richtig zur ruhe gekommen ich war klar wenn du 100 wenn du
105 puls hast da kommst du nicht zur ruhe du bist nicht zur ruhe gekommen
und dadurch hatte ich dann auch noch so ganz ganz komisches zeug das
kenne das manchmal wenn man
wenn man einschläft
manchmal
Wenn man wenn man einschläft dann dann zuckt einem so das bein oder der arm oder so mal ganz kurz und dann denkst du
dass das ist auch da gibt es noch eine wikipedia seite zu dass das ist so quasi so
Da schickt das hier in falsche signale so beim einschlafen das kommt manchmal vor es hatte wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal
das kommt nicht oft vor aber manchmal manchmal hat man das
Und das hatte ich das hatte ich laufend
Wahrscheinlich weil ich halt nicht nicht kommt weil ich nicht einschlafen konnte wegen dem hohen puls das war richtig kacke ich habe versucht
Dazu liegen ich habe nichts ich habe nichts gemacht ich habe mich nicht bewegt nur ich habe einfach nur ruhig da gelegen und ich konnte
Nicht einschlafen wenn ich gerade am einschlafen war hat so mein arm von alleine gewackelt und so ganz merkwürdig
Leute ich sage euch dass das das corona war nicht das schlimme an corona sondern das drumherum war mega beschissen
Dazu kam natürlich noch das übliche was ich hatte also ich habe
also
Die sache also ich habe anders andere sachen also die sachen nicht mal geschmeckt und was auch sehr was was auch ganz wird champ war
Das roch auch alles anders also ich habe dann in der eig im eigenen haus hier in der eigenen wohnung habe ich gedacht
Das ist anders als sonst
Weil sich das weil das alles sich anders angefühlt hat dadurch und da ist dann aber auch ein bisschen schlecht durch geworden die
Also ohne scheiß das ist wirklich was was ich nicht wiederhaben will
Ich hatte mich ich war zum damaligen zeitpunkt auch schon geimpft und und ich habe wahrscheinlich also ich glaube die letzte information ein bisschen her aber
Wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich habe ich dadurch auch nicht man kann man ja nur vermuten aber
Wahrscheinlich habe ich dadurch auch jetzt nicht in der vollen vollen breite abgekriegt oder es hätte vielleicht noch schlimmer laufen können aber es war
Schon eklig also es war wirklich eklig corona das will ich nicht haben das nächste mal wenn ich es kriege falls ich also ich hoffe
Gar nicht dass ich es kriege wenn ich es kriege ob ich das nächste mal ist auch so wie es viele hatten dass man gar nichts von
merkt
Das war kacke also das wird das will ich das will ich echt nicht noch mal haben ja und danach war ich auch noch
Zwei drei wochen richtig im arsch ich weiß noch als wir wieder ein bisschen besser ging
Bin ich bin ich an meinen runter und wollten wollten stück laufen und ich habe so ein viertel von der normalen strecke und fünftel fünftel eher
Von der normalen runde die sonst halt die normale runde dauert so knapp knapp um eine stunde
Die laufe ich immer wenn halt wenn wetter nicht gut ist oder sowas aber ich trotzdem eine stunde am tag laufen will ich habe
Ein fünftel von der runde geschafft
Mehr mehr ging nicht da muss dann musste ich erst mal zehn minuten mich auf eine bank setzen und wieder zurücklaufen so wie der größte
Rentner überhaupt
Ja das war schon kacke wie gesagt behandelt wurde wurde die lebensmittel vergiftung gar nicht das muss man einfach abwarten
Ich hatte es direkt nach dem ersten tag ja
Halt toll also damals auf die idee gekommen sind so nach dem motto ach wisst ihr was
Homeoffice Homeoffice ist ja eigentlich eine tolle sache aber wir können doch alle ich weiß ich weiß ich wie es bei dir war potato
Bob aber die haben sich dann management technisch super
Weird champige dinger aus den fingern gesaugt beim alter beim alten arbeitgeber wo ich wo ich gearbeitet habe so nach dem motto ja
Homeoffice war eigentlich ganz toll und wir bedanken uns auch noch mal bei allen wie gut das funktioniert hat aber sind wir doch mal
ehrlich am besten können menschen immer noch vor ort zusammenarbeiten und nachdem unser unternehmen ja von menschen für menschen steht und
wir
deswegen
Kommen jetzt wieder alle ins büro und sowas in der richtung
Das problem war nur dass die leute nicht mitgemacht haben
Das haben die halt erzählt und haben halt gedacht die leute kommen jetzt alle wieder freiwillig ins büro und die sind alle nicht freiwillig
ins büro gekommen die haben alle gesagt
sinngemäß
Wenn ich das jetzt finden würde okay keine ahnung ich finde den sound gerade nicht aber die haben alle gesagt pisst nicht alle
Die hatten alle keinen bock und sind trotzdem sind trotzdem zum größten teil im homeoffice geblieben
Und dann ging es aber beim alten arbeitnehmer richtig richtig zur sache die nächsten paar monate über
Erst erst kamen irgendwelche ansprachen so nach dem motto wie toll das doch recht menschlich zusammenzuarbeiten die leute sollen doch wieder ins
büro kommen also die leute sind schon ins büro gekommen aber halt das mindestmaß was was gefordert also was
quasi
Schriftlich gefordert war ja so und
Dann haben die ja die ganze zeit erzählt so und es wäre auch so toll vor ort zu arbeiten
Ich kann mich noch an einen termin erinnern da waren irgendwelche leute vom frag mich nicht von der personalabteilung oder vom
Marketing war nie glaube ich und die haben tatsächlich auf so einer veranstaltung
erzählt wie toll ihr letztes offline event war
Und das haben wir garantiert nur eingebaut dass die leute sagen
Ja ist schon cool gewesen vor ort ich komme jetzt wieder fünf tage die woche vor ort und sowas die haben so eine richtige
Lobeshymne auf ihr letztes offline event und wie toll das war und wie schön dass man sich auch mal wieder gesehen hat und die leute
Haben sich alle nur gedacht es labert mich nicht voll alle ich komme die geforderte anzahl rest bleibe ich daheim
Homeoffice und hat die letzten zwei jahre gesehen es funktioniert wunderbar wenn nicht sogar besser
Es geht mir mal nicht auf den keks sondern ging es halt immer weiter
Es ging halt
Gegen die ganze zeit also und irgendwann kam sie dann auch an mit
Jetzt wird es jetzt wird es wieder pflicht weil es hat sich hat keiner dran gehalten
Und dann wurde es immer mehr pflicht mittlerweile habe ich gehört ich bin ja bin ja weg dort
Mittlerweile habe ich gehört das letzte was ich von dem thema gehört habe von jemand
der noch dort arbeitet ist also die letzte entwicklung bei meinem alten arbeitgeber ist nicht mehr so wie
Angeblich also das letzte was sie mir erzählt haben weil ich auch immer gesagt habe mir geht das auf den keks und das ist auch
Ein grund warum ich jetzt abhaue mir haben sie damals immer erzählt so nach dem motto
Ja max zweimal die woche anwesenheit also für die nicht zweimal die woche stimmte gar nicht 50 prozent
Sind ja sind ja im prinzip bei mir zwei zwei tage 50 prozent anwesenheit
Da wird ich habe damals also ich habe den damals schon gesagt also guck mal ihr habt jetzt von
Guckt mal guckt mal dass ihr da seid wenn was wichtiges vor ort ist zu ein tag zu zwei tagen pflicht fünf und jetzt seid ihr
über 50 prozent was bei leuten die vollzeit arbeiten quasi theoretisch sogar ein bisschen mehr ist
Ihr seid jetzt innerhalb von von wir können es mit unseren vorgesetzten ausmachen und es passt schon wenn ihr euch da einig seid zu
50 prozent anwesenheit pflicht da habe ich denen damals ja auch gesagt wie lange dauert es denn bis man sagt einfach 80 prozent wieder
Und da haben sie mir immer gesagt so nach dem motto nein nein nein nein das wird nicht passieren
Also zwei tage und so 50 das ist das höchste worauf wir pflicht anwesenheit gehen werden
So und das letzte was ich jetzt gehört habe von einem der noch dort arbeitet ist dass sie gesagt haben volle anwesenheit
Volle anwesenheit mit mit
einem einem tag homeoffice die woche möglichkeit in ausnahmefällen in begründeten ausnahmefällen da musste wahrscheinlich noch bitte bitte sagen
Vielleicht zwei tage also es ist genau das passiert was was ich mir gedacht habe was auch eines der gründe war warum ich gesagt habe
Ich haue jetzt letztendlich ab ja
und das ist halt
Dieses gelaber das hat mich dann irgendwie dazu gebracht
Mit dazu gebracht dass ich gewechselt habe weil du dich halt auf nichts mehr verlassen konntest was die gesagt haben
Das ist aber also 105 für 105 ruhrpuls hier wenn man vom rechner hängt ist ganz schön viel
Es sei denn du zappelst hier gerade wie wild rum oder bist vorhin hier rum
Durch den raum rum gesprungen weil ich gefreut dass das das stream on ist oder sowas
Keine ahnung das ist auch ein thema wozu ich im stream jetzt nicht
Mich weiter auslassen will weil das thema ist durch und immer wenn du was dazu sagst geht es ab
Ich denke es soll jeder so machen wie er es für richtig hält und pflicht halte ich übrigens in dem fall auch nix
Aber das ist ja glücklicherweise nicht mehr nicht mehr auf dem tisch
Hat nie durchgehen jeder hat so einen zettel bekommen dass wir zur arbeit fahren dürfen und das ist aber nett
Das ist aber nett von von eurem von eurem arbeitgeber dass er das da dass sie das dürft achso während dem ersten lockdown
Ja, so einen zettel hatte ich auch
Ich hatte auch so einen zettel dass ich wie haben sie das genannt
Es ist es hieß nicht wichtige person es hieß
Wie haben sie das noch mal genannt also zumindest hatte ich so einen zettel vom hessischen
Lobminister ministerium frag mich nicht von welchem dass ich in einem
Wie haben sie das genannt dass ich in einem beruf arbeite der quasi
Wichtig wichtig ist für das öffentliche leben oder nicht für für irgendwie sowas in der richtung also
wir haben halt wir haben halt so einen zettel gekriegt wo drin stand dass wir
Im bevorzug glaube ich auch auch impfung und so erhalten können wenn wir wollen
Weil wir irgendwie in einem wichtigen job arbeiten das wurde damit begründet weil halt bank und aufrechterhaltung von it in der bank wäre
Halt wichtig für das so quasi so was sagen so dass dass unsere gesellschaft weiter
Funktioniert und deswegen wäre das wäre das essenzieller so einen zettel hatte ich
Wobei ich von dem zettel
Systemkritisch irgendwie sowas ja wobei ich von dem zettel keinen gebrauch gemacht habe bei mir gab es keinen engpass
Irgendwie ich wollte eh nicht ganz vorne mit dabei sein was das impfen angeht
aber
Danach gab es da eigentlich ja gar keine
Ja also eile mehr zumal ich eh home office hatte durchgehend das heißt ich hatte eh keine chance großartig mir anzustecken
Man wollte dass ich für 30 minuten meeting ins büro komme und ja so ein schwachsinn
Also aktuell funktioniert es bei mir auf der neuen arbeit funktioniert
Folgendermaßen wir haben als einzige vorgabe
dass wir im durchschnitt
Einmal die woche da sein sollen
Und was ich jetzt schon gehört habe ist dass das angeblich eines der restriktiveren
Regelungen bei uns in der it ist wo ich sagen muss wenn das von die restriktive regelung ist dann ist das vollkommen okay für mich
So und also wir können auch mal eine woche nicht kommen oder so und zumindest aktuell mache ich das so
Ich bin immer jede zweite woche dienstag da
Weil wir dort so einen tag haben wo den ganzen tag durch gemietet wird und dann einmal sonst die woche
Irgendwie so irgendwie was passt nächste woche wahrscheinlich mittwoch
Weil ich da mit einem kolleg essen gehe
Ja das ist eigentlich eine super regelung habe ich überhaupt gar keine schmerzen mit theoretisch könnte ich jetzt auch sagen ist ja unfair
Leute die vollzeit arbeiten nur einen tag und ich arbeite vier tage auch einen tag das müsste doch bei mir dann eigentlich auch 80 prozent
also quasi
Alle vier wochen einmal nicht ganz ehrlich auf so diskussionen habe ich keinen bock wozu auch ich habe damit überhaupt keine schmerzen ich
komme ein tag die woche nach frankfurt
und
Legt das meistens so dass es halt auch der tag ist wo ich dauerhaft mieten muss weil da muss ich für da sein das bietet
sich halt einfach an
Und dann ist gut das kann ich kann ich mit leben und da habe ich auch den eindruck man kann sich darauf verlassen
dass diese diese regelung die stehen ja halt bei uns auch offiziell geschrieben überall
ja und
Da kann man sich wenigstens darauf verlassen da hat noch keiner was gesagt mit aber wir müssen das jetzt ändern weil man hat man sieht
Dort es funktioniert auch einfach gut
Das kannst du wenn also wenn du auf sowas stehst kannst du das sicherlich auch auf was andere auf anderen veranstaltungen machen als auf eurem sommerfest der firma
Wenn es einem danach ist warum nicht
Es gab letztens auch eine einladung bei uns meilenstein im projekt ist erreicht
Veranstaltung abends 21 uhr bis 23 uhr an einem mittwoch gehe ich auch nicht hin
21 uhr in frankfurt bis drei mittwoch
Also hätten die das freitags gemacht
Dann hätte man sich das vielleicht noch überlegen können wobei ihr kennt mich ich wäre wahrscheinlich auch nicht dahin gegangen weil ich so veranstaltungen nicht
mag aber mittwoch
21 bis 23 weil da kann es ja gleich in frankfurt übernachten
Ne also da habe ich habe ich auch gleich abgesagt
Während er war bei uns kurzarbeit angemeldet
Und darauf bestanden dass wir trotzdem arbeiten ist nicht nur illegal aber die hätte war dass danach behauptet wurde dass man so ja gesehen hat
dass er
Also was das ist halt richtiger boomerladen dann ja
das
Da haben sie halt ihre eigene fail planung wieder verkackt
Und festgestellt wir haben kacke geplant und dann gesagt die leute sind schuld so was aber das schlimme ist das schlimme ist
Wisst ihr was also die wahrscheinlich glauben die das wirklich dass es dass man daran gesehen hat dass es nicht funktioniert
Die sind das komplett los teilweise
Aber mir ist es meistens dienstag
Das ist die beste kombination das hatte ich das hatte ich naja also ja das ist die beste kombination
Aber das hatte ich bei meinem letzten arbeitgeber auch da hatte ich auch einen chef der war selbst
Der meinung home office beste ja hat es auch selbst so weit wie möglich natürlich ging es bei ihm nicht ganz so viel wenn die
Irgendwelche führungskräfte veranstaltung vorhaben aber der hat wenn es geht das auch gemacht
Und den haben sie dann entsorgt nach
Drei vier jahren wurde unser chef war haben sie entsorgt der hat zu oft
Unangenehme dinger ausgesprochen wobei ich der meinung bin der hat das richtig gemacht
Der hat nämlich die sachen die halt nicht gut gelaufen sind oftmals zwar ein bisschen
So ein bisschen management angepasst aber hat die wenigstens weitergegeben das ist das ist das was ich von einem ordentlichen vorgesetzten oder vom guten vorgesetzen auch
Chef teamleiter was auch immer erwarten würde dass der beides weitergibt ja also
Sowohl von oben als auch in die andere richtung und nicht immer nur in eine richtung weil
Das erzeugt ja das an der stelle ja auch wichtig weil es erzeugt so einen so einen leicht schizophrenen
Eindruck dass man immer sachen erzählt bekommt
Obwohl man davon weiß dass sie in der wirklichkeit nicht so sind wisst ihr also also es ist ja so irgendjemand sagen wir mal
Führungsführungsebene denkt sich irgendwas aus das und das das wollen wir jetzt machen dass es so unser unser ziel für die nächste zeit
Und das kriegst du dann erzählt und dann setzt du das setzt das um und aus irgendwelchen gründen
Läuft dann doch ein bisschen anders wie geplant so und wenn dieses es läuft anders wie geplant
Nichts richtig kommuniziert wird wenn anstatt
Okay, wir haben zwei wochen verzögerung kommuniziert wird alles ganz toll und wir wir sind voll im zeitplan
dann hört man dann von oben so dinger wie wir gehen in zwei wochen live und
alles alles ganz toll und du guckst dich dann an und denkst so
Wie wollt ihr in zwei wochen live gehen
Das steht noch nicht mal die domains beantragt so nach dem motto wie wollt ihr in zwei wochen live gehen
Das ist deswegen es ist wichtig dass das
Gerade vorgesetzt an dieser management position auch sachen von unten nach oben transportieren und nicht nur umgedreht zumindest
Das hat er das hat er halt auch gemacht er hat ihm wurde damals immer gesagt so nach dem motto firma will kein homeoffice
Weil irgendwelche leute das überlegt haben und jetzt überzeugt mal und erklärt und sagt dass deinen leuten
Und das hat er uns halt auch gesagt das ist jetzt die kurzfassung
Ja haben schon ein bisschen mehr gesagt hat uns dann auch gesagt und haben leute von uns gesagt das gefällt ihnen nicht da haben die
Keinen bock drauf manche haben auch gesagt also wenn ihr das wirklich durchsetzt dann hauen wir ab ich habe das damals nicht gesagt
Ich
Hab das erst ich habe das erst ein jahr später oder so ungefähr ja ungefähr ein jahr später dann gesagt als ich gesehen habe
Die ziehen das die wollen das wirklich durchziehen da bin ich ja dann auch weg
Und das hat er so weitergegeben hat gesagt okay
Also feedback von meiner gruppe war die leute haben keinen bock
Das hat er alles ein bisschen schöner verkauft gehe ich mal von aus ja aber da hat schon ihnen gesagt okay die entscheidung ist nicht
Auf die gegenliebe gestoßen die wollen das nicht und paar leute haben auch gesagt
Das werden sie wenn sie so nicht mitmachen das hat er weitergegeben und das kam halt überhaupt nicht gut an dass er einfach klartext
Gesprochen hat wie auf also oftmals wie entscheidung angekommen sind beziehungsweise wie sachen gelaufen sind
Und die wollten das halt nur geschönt haben das war halt auch so ein punkt wo ich mir gedacht habe
Dass das obere management bei der letzten arbeitgeber wo ich wo ich gearbeitet habe habe ich mittlerweile nur noch zwei möglichkeiten was das gewesen sein
Kann entweder dass sie echt komplett disconnected zu jeglicher realität waren und einfach nur planlos ist auch durchaus möglich
Oder dass es in irgendeiner art und weise taktik war
Wo ich aber nicht genau weiß warum also die zwei sachen kann ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen ich kann
Wahrscheinlich waren sie planlos das würde zu dem laden ganz gut passen
Zumindest das hat das ist ihm letztendlich halt auch zum verhängnis geworden die haben ja quasi also meinen ehemaligen chef haben sie entsorgt
höchstwahrscheinlich weil er zu oft gesagt hat
Wie bestimmte entscheidungen angenommen wurden beziehungsweise angekommen sind da hat er einfach gesagt wie das was wo man eigentlich von ausgehen sollte
Das ist nicht schlecht wenn man das weiß
Aber das wollten sie anscheinend nicht
Moin nico
Ja
Sollte ich auch mal probieren ehemalige kollegen abzuwerben
Wir haben da noch so zwei zwei leute die ich so im hinterkopf habe die wir echt gut gebrauchen könnten dort in dem neuen laden wo ich
jetzt bin
Könnten wir echt gebrauchen
Montag ja ich habe ich bin montags nicht da
Ich bin aber ich arbeite montags prinzipiell nicht also
Arbeite montags schon was aber nicht für die firma
Also nicht nicht dort wo ich hauptsächlich arbeite weil ihr wisst ja ich arbeite 80 prozent montags habe ich frei
Nee weiß nicht zumindest gab es bei uns noch keine panzer auf dem flur
Ja also wir sind da nicht alleine das weiß ich auch
Also wenn du rum guckst ganz ganz viele große unternehmen gerade so klassisch
oldschool unternehmen ja versicherungen banken
was auch immer so dinger so halt mit gibt es schon seit 300 jahren gefühlt und und
führungsriege alle 60 plus oder so
Ich glaube die haben ähnliche probleme
Da sind aber auch die die keine leute finden ja das ist auch witzig also ich ich weiß bei meinem alten arbeitgeber hatten sie halt
Stellen anzeigen die waren auch nicht sonderlich gut aber sei es drum habe ich euch schon öfters erzählt dass ich da auch ein bisschen
Feedback öfters hingeschickt hat was sie was sie nicht interessiert hat ich meine die müssen die hätten sich eins zu eins so schreiben müssen wie
Ich es geschrieben habe das erwarte ich logischerweise nicht aber hätte aber zumindest ein paar sachen daraus übernehmen können weil ich denke das hätte die
Stellenanzeige deutlich attraktiver und besser gemacht
so und
Das ist halt auch so richtige richtige boomerriege gewesen die da selbst kein bock drauf hatten und dann ist ihnen halt aufgefallen so die finden
Keine leute und ich habe von meinem chef damals öfters gehört dass bewerbungsgespräche beziehungsweise bewerber
Ja wie nennt man das so erstkontakte folgendermaßen gelaufen sind ja also entweder hat sich einer auf die stellenanzeige beworben
Oder irgendein vermittler dude meinte ich hätte da jemand für euch sondern das lief dann so
dann wurde wurde halt die
Der lebenslauf und und die skills und sowas ausgetauscht da hat man sich leute rausgesucht wo man gesagt
Die würden ja ganz gut passen so und da gab es also den ersten kontakt wo man mal telefoniert hat mit den leuten beziehungsweise
Über den vermittler die leute was gefragt hat und sich ausgetauscht hat zumindest das erste was dann immer kommt
Oder immer kam von den bewerbern war wie ist dann wie ist dann die homeoffice regelung beziehungsweise die remote
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten bei ihnen also hat mir hat mir so mein alter chef erzählt ja wie wäre denn die remote arbeit
Also die remote homeoffice möglichkeiten bei ihnen im unternehmen
Und da hat er halt dann gesagt okay er hat halt ehrlich darauf geantwortet gesagt ja jetzt gerade während der korona während korona
Sachen noch laufen da ist relativ gut aber danach wird zum größten teil anwesenheit wieder erwartet und die leute haben dann insgesamt gesagt
Okay, tschüss
Kein interesse mehr also sie haben alle gesagt als sie das gehört haben haben wir keinen bock drauf
Und die haben halt keine leute gefunden und die stellen anzeigen sie lustigerweise immer noch offen
Also wir haben stellen anzeigen drei jahre offen gehabt immer die gleiche scheiß stellen anzeige und immer der gleiche kram und das hat bis
Jetzt also der musste noch langsamer was dämmern wahrscheinlich ist das aber auch so dass dann dort gesagt wird
Oh der fachkräfte oder muss sagen mein alter arbeitgeber ist wirklich kein unbekannter kleiner laden also die haben geld ohne ende die können
sich das ohne probleme leisten da
Einmal ein bisschen ein bisschen das alles ein bisschen ordentlich zu machen ja und das ist immer noch offen
Wahrscheinlich sagen die auch. Oh fachkräftemangel niemand möchte das machen ja gut natürlich will das keine unter den voraussetzungen machen
vor allem wenn er halt alternativen hat mittlerweile
Ich weiß auch nicht also gut aber der zum glück zum glück ist der ist das bei mir hat sich erledigt ich bin wirklich froh im
Nachhinein jetzt da ich das gemacht habe ich bin jetzt ziemlich genau
Drei monate beim neuen arbeitgeber also ich habe anfang april angefangen das ist ja quasi april
also april mai juni drei monate
Und ich bin in vielen bereichen immer noch ziemlich lost was da wie wie wie wohl läuft und so aber ich blicke
mittlerweile halbwegs wieder durch ich ich müsste demnächst auch
Ich müsste demnächst auch mit meinem chef glaube ich dass das probezeit halbzeit
Gespräch haben da muss ich auch noch ein paar sachen los wenn ich habe extra so einen so ein feedback dokument gemacht was mir aufgefallen ist
Ja und das war im endeffekt aber doch die richtige entscheidung
Es ist natürlich ein bisschen ein bisschen anstrengender als im alten laden aktuell muss man auch klar sagen
Was auch bisschen auswirkungen darauf hat ein bisschen weniger videos mache gerade auf youtube es ist ein bisschen anstrengender das liegt aber zum größten teil daran
Weil man hat die sache noch nicht kennt beim alten arbeitgeber war das halt so
Da kann das da alles schon auswendig da wusstest du eigentlich genau so müssen das machen okay heißt so und so und so okay alles klar
Ich mache das mal so im halbschlaf
Und da ist es halt so ich ich kenne halt viele abläufe dort noch nicht und wie man sachen macht da muss ich mir das halt
Angucken aber das ist jetzt schon viel viel besser geworden
Also bei den bei den meisten sachen die mich so direkt betreffen blicke ich jetzt schon durch aber es ist halt es ist halt schon
Ein unterschied ob die dir dann halt immer angucken muss was du machst oder ob das schon aus dem ff kannst
Also so für irgendwelche workflows und abläufe und interne regelung und so das ist halt gut wenn man die wenn man die einfach schon kennt
Aber in spätestens drei vier monaten hat sich das dann auch erledigt und dann
Dann ist da auch ein bisschen mehr easy mode
Bei uns ist gerade richtig die kacke am dampfen der der geldgeber
Macht richtig druck weil er letztes jahr versprochen hat ja das war eher ein selbsthüter
Homeoffice ist das geringste problem die arbeit gibt
Ja sehe ich auch so ich meine ich kann es verstehen in manchen bereichen
Ja, also wenn jetzt die marketing leute sagen
Wir können unsere krassen
high iq
Downstorming white chart mal aktionen nur vor ort machen sollen sie machen aber sollen uns halt it technisch in ruhe lassen
Weil ob ich mich jetzt auf linux server einlogge
Oder irgendwas deploy oder irgendwelche sachen kommitte oder was auch immer ob ich das jetzt vor ort mache
Wo ich quasi zu 95 prozent des tages an meinem rechner sitze ohne ohne mit anderen leuten da was zusammen zu machen
Außer ein bisschen zu schwätzen und im endeffekt sogar weniger zu arbeiten als daheim dadurch
Es ist eigentlich kein unterschied ich finde es aber ganz gut
So also ein tag ein tag die woche im büro ist für mich wirklich der beste kompromiss
Da siehst du mal ein paar leute vor ort kannst vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen über irgendwas ablästern oder irgendwas
Irgendwas belabern und dann ist wieder gut ja wobei ich sagen muss
Also zum aktuellen arbeitgeber kann ich nichts sagen weil ich habe da die corona zeit nicht erlebt
Aber am alten arbeitgeber muss man sagen wir haben in der corona zeit wo alle daheim waren
Wahrscheinlich mehr miteinander gesprochen und zusammengearbeitet als vor ort vor ort war das bei uns früher immer so du hattest leute die waren den
Ganzen tag im meeting die waren den ganzen tag am telefon
Und wenn du sie dann mal gesucht hast an ihrem platz waren sie gerade nicht da
Und das war über teams viel einfacher du hast geguckt der typ ist auf grün hast auf anrufen gedrückt der war dran
Und was du halt direkt gemerkt hast sind leute die multiplayer gaming erfahrung haben weiß ich ob ich das auch schon festgestellt habe
Du hattest du hattest das thema home office angeht
Hast du super ultra boomer die quasi das mikrofon im poppen stecken haben und nix technisch auf die reihe kriegen und du hast leute die
Haben multiplayer game erfahrung die benutzen sogar push to talk und solche sachen also die haben die am funktionieren das audio equipment
Die wissen wie man ihre software bedient die wissen auch dass man sich mutet wenn gerade kachel im hintergrund ist und so was du kannst
Sofort feststellen wer online gaming erfahrung hat und wenn ich ja zeig her zeig her
Er schreibt bei meinem alten abgeber suchen sie ein sysadmin für zitat windows server landschaft wenn man sowas ekliges machen will schick her ich gucke es mir an
Korrekt korrekt es sind ja aber witzigerweise nicht nur die jungen leute es sind ja auch leute wie ich die jetzt fast 39 sind
Die haben da auch keinen bock mehr drauf ich habe mir übrigens sagen lassen ich bin ich bin nicht jung und ich bin nicht alt
Wisst ihr was es für ein buzzword gibt für meine generation
Und ich meine damit jetzt nicht generation y oder sowas best ager habe ich mir sagen lassen letztens best ager
Klingt ein bisschen giga chat mäßig oder kannst du mal darauf reagieren okay habe ich haben wir uns das nicht so schon angeguckt
Aber medics schick schick rüber ich gucke mir gerne solche stellen anzeigen an und lässt ein bisschen drüber ab
Aber nur wenn sich also nur wenn es ablästerbare gründe gibt
Es gibt beides es gibt beides es gibt beides
Ein fachkräftemangel gibt es schon aber bei weitem nicht in dem ausmaß wie es in statistiken so aussieht
Kommt noch ein bisschen auf die statistik an mit was für einen notendurchschnitt in den relevanten statistiken
Und dann gibt es natürlich auch noch ein paar grundsätzliche grundsätzliche grundsätzliche grundsätzliche grundsätzliche grundsätzliche
Kommt noch ein bisschen auf die statistik an mit was für einen notendurchschnitt in den relevanten schulflächen hast du damals deine ausbildung begonnen
Boah keine ahnung weißt du wie lange das her ist also nicht nur die ausbildung begonnen sondern mein mein mein normaler schulabschluss
Keine ahnung das weiß ich nicht
Ernsthaft keine Ahnung
Das zeugt mich war jetzt nicht sonderlich gut das kann ich dir sagen aber ich habe keine Ahnung mehr was das für ein durchschnitt war
Ich muss mal kurz meine vm anmachen um das pdf zu öffnen man weiß ja nie
Können wir auch gleich mal vm update machen
Aber wir müssen auch github trends angucken wir haben jetzt ganz schön viel geschwätzt fast eine stunde
Das ist immer gut wenn man das spürt das ist auch eine der sache die mich bei meinem aktuellen arbeitgeber tatsächlich nicht überzeugt hat hinzugehen
Aber überzeugt hat also ein weiterer punkt der mich überzeugt hat dass es die richtige richtige wahl war dort hinzugehen
Und zwar ich war letztens mit einem entwickler futtern bei uns in der kantine der ist da wohl irgendwie schon 20 jahre oder so
Schon ein bisschen länger da und da haben wir auch so ein bisschen über entwicklung so von it technik jobs und so geredet
Und er meinte er ist froh wie sich das die letzten 5-6 jahre zum positiven verändert hat dort wo ich jetzt bin sonst wäre er vielleicht auch nicht mehr da
Weil früher war es so dass man hauptsächlich immer wenn was kaputt gegangen ist und so versucht hat rauszubekommen wer es war und die leute haben dann anschiss bekommen
Was dazu geführt hat dass eigentlich jeder schiss hatte was zu machen und die leute den ganzen tag da gesessen haben und lieber nichts gemacht haben
Anstatt was zu machen weil wenn du möglichst viel gemacht hast ist es nicht dass du vorteile davon hattest du hast eher nachteile gehabt dadurch wenn du viel gemacht hast
Weil auch viel öfters was kaputt gegangen ist also sprich es war besser für dich du hast einfach nur da gesessen und nichts gemacht weil dann auch nichts kaputt gehen konnte
Und das hat sich die letzten 5-6 jahre extrem gewandelt und also wohl auch mit dem neuen it chef und alles extrem gewandelt und ist jetzt viel besser wie vorher
Ja das fand ich schon mal nicht schlecht weil in die richtung ging es ja bei meinem alten arbeitgeber auch dass du eher gesagt hast okay du machst lieber weniger
Anstatt freiwillig in Anführungsstrichen mehr weil wenn du mehr machst interessiert das keinen wenn bei diesem mehr machen vielleicht ab und zu mal was kaputt geht
Kriegst du aber einen Anschiss also insofern warum sollte man mehr machen so und das hat mich schon wieder überzeugt dass ich da tatsächlich wohl zum richtigen laden gewechselt bin jetzt wo das nicht so ist
Woher ist der Hintergrund von der vm den findest du hier auf github guck wobblers white pepo happy background destiny white pepo happy desktop
Ja warte mal ich poste das mal in den chat da findest du noch mehr da findest du auch also du findest für jede tageszeit 4-5 passende bilder
Guck du hast hier für mittagessen hast du ihn hast keks wird gefuttert beim arbeiten ist er booster haut er sich rein ein bild zum weitere bilder machen
Hier isst er gerade was am essen hier trinkt er kaffee oder tee und isst seine sein muesli
Tee mit croissants war warmer tee kalter tee was auch immer nachts schläft er und träumt zu sachen wie c++ monkaS
Sonnenaufgang ist er am zähneputzen oder am youtube gucken und dann ist er am ins bett gehen
Du hast auch ein skript dabei wobei das kannst du ja ohne probleme selbst machen du hast ein skript dabei was die die hintergründe setzt alle 10 minuten passend zur tageszeit
Sogar theoretisch mit zeitzonen infos drin da hat der max wieder übertrieben aber kannst natürlich die bilder auch einfach so benutzen
Warum bin ich nochmal in die vma weil ich das pdf zeigen wollte machen wir gleich pdf document
Okay pass auf da steht jetzt debated drin boah das ist doch bestimmt 1 zu 1 word document kopiert oder?
Kann man sich da nicht irgendwie die details anzeigen lassen das ist doch bestimmt word doc ursprünglich gewesen
Es ist auch sehr gestaucht alles okay also zeig mal her steigen sie ein bei den innsbrucker verkehrsbedingungen das ist sowas wie der rmv bei mir in der ecke
Wir bewegen die stadt stellen sie jetzt die weichen für ihre erfolgreiche zukunft mit einem ich mein der introsatz ist okay ne
Ich finde den zwar ein bisschen abgetroschen mit wir machen verkehr und machen stellen weichen aber das ist bei weitem nicht so schlimm wie manch andere
Weil die meisten die meisten dinger die meisten stellen anzeigen fangen an mit wir sind xyz und führen im bereich sowieso
Und das geht das ist so langweilig immer der gleiche kram
Stellen sie jetzt die weichen für ihre erfolgreiche zukunft mit einem job bei der ivb
Zusammen mit rund 300 kolleginnen arbeiten sie direkt an den organisationen der emissionsfreien mobilität von morgen
Sie profitieren von flexibilitäten arbeitszeit modellen ausgezeichnen sozialleistung und guter work lifebildung
Okay klingt doch schon mal nicht schlecht
Zur verstärkung unseres teams suchen wir eine einen it systemadministrator männlich weiß deutsch
Sie haben eine abgeschlossene it ausbildung ja das gut das wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt dafür
Wir bieten ihnen eine abwechslungsreiche und verachtungsvolle verantwortungsvolle aufgabe
Sie haben sich rasch entwickelt in einem technischen umfeld nach einer intensiven Einstellungsphase arbeiten sie als der spider
Telematik it schwerpunkt haben wir hier office 365 cloud ist auch sehr nichts sagen aber okay
Office 365
Na gut wem es gefällt cloud fahrzeugkommunikation security und digitalisierung sind ein
Ey Leute das ist ja aber komplett also jetzt mal seriös office 365 ist ja noch was konkretes ja
Aber cloud da kann ich auch sagen ja kennen sie sich aus mit computer das ist ungefähr genauso breit gefasst ja
Ja oder irgendeinen arzt zu fragen so ja und sagt ihnen medizin was oder den schreiner was ist ihre meinung von holz
Also cloud kann ja alles alles und nichts wieder bedeuten okay fahrzeugkommunikation kann man sich auch konkret was
Security und digitalisierung sind auch so komplett global galaktische begriffe die alles und nichts bedeuten können
Sind einige schwerpunkte ihrer tätigkeit wir arbeiten produktiv mit dem mit den aktuellsten microsoft technologien da okay
Naja es ist halt windows windows gedörnt ja zu ihren aufgaben zählen der
Da hört es schon auf da hört es schon auf
First level support
Da ist schon direkt vorbei die administration und konfiguration der server okay du machst quasi
Moment Moment Moment
First und second level support die administration der server auf basis von microsoft und linux platform die betreuung der internen
Netzwerkstruktur sowie die umsetzung von internet okay du machst alles du bist du bist die it abteilung
Das ist so ein typisches ding wo etwas weniger schreiben mehr gewesen wäre du bist du bist die it abteilung in einer person
Wahrscheinlich bist du wahrscheinlich haben die wirklich nicht mehr du bist wahrscheinlich wirklich der einzige
Admin wie warum brauchen wir wir haben doch schon einen admin warum brauchen wir da mehrere admins der macht doch alles
Der macht der darf auch nie krank werden und am wochenende macht er auch alles
Ich meine guck mal office also cloud office
Digitalisierung first level support second level support windows linux
Netzwerk und projekte externe projekte auch noch okay
Das ist halt wirklich so eine ganze it abteilung in einem wieder
Weiters weiters im weiteren oder weiters das der satz ist doch nicht richtig oder weiters arbeiten sie auch
In österreich macht man das so okay weiters arbeiten sie auch
Ach das ist at
Dann dann erklärt sich das alles
Weiters arbeiten sie auch an der umsetzung technischer sicherheitsrichtlinien
Und das steht ja oben schon
Das bieten wir ihnen arbeiten sie in einem motivierten team
Zahlreiche aus- und weiterbildungsmöglichkeit das schreiben sie alle immer ein umfangreiches angebot an gesundheitsleistung
Vergünstigung für die freizeit von sportkursen bis hin zum klimaticket tirol
Okay warum nicht
Die entlohnung entspricht den
Oje oje
Oh da steht ja mal wirklich eine zahl drin
Die entlohnung entspricht den bestimmungen des kollektivvertrags für die beschäftigten der österreichischen eisenweinunternehmen und beträgt
Mitbereitschaft zur überzahlung was soll denn mitbereitschaft zur überzahlung bedeuten
Achso man bekommt mehr wenn man mehr qualifiziert ist
Aber mal im ernst
Wahrscheinlich auch noch 12 mal 12 monate
Hahahaha
Ganz bestimmt
Loll
Hahahaha
Das ist ja nix
Das ist ja nix alter
Hahahaha
Also ganz ehrlich
Leute
Es war ernsthaft
Um das mal um das mal
Ins
Ins verhältnis zu setzen
Mein aller aller erstes gehalt
Und das war damals jetzt auch schon nicht der absolute wahnsinn
Ja mein aller aller erstes gehalt
Damals nach der ausbildung beim provider
Also das ist das ist
13 14 jahre her
Da hab ich 33.500
Also muss ich das mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen
Mein erstes gehalt was ich nach der ausbildung
Je in meinem leben bekommen habe
Vor 15 jahren runden wir es mal auf
War mehr als was die hier wollen
Für jemand mit berufserfahrung
Und und die komplette
IT Abteilung in einem
Äh im im Jahr
Also ich mein sind das sind das
Sind das 14 Monats Gehälter
Wenn das 14 sind ja
Dann ist es immer noch wenig
Also das ist ja nur wirklich lächerlich wenig
Auch wenn es Windows Geschiss ist
Und ich und ich immer sagen ja okay
Windows Leute haben hier eh alle keinen Plan
Aber stimmt ja nicht
Hä also wie kommt man
Wie kommt man denn ernsthaft auf die Idee
Eine komplette IT Abteilung in einer Person zu suchen
Und dann den noch nicht mal was bezahlen zu wollen
Was verdienst du
Jetzt im Monat
Mehr als das hier
Ähm
Ich verdiene pass auf
Wir haben da immer ganz gute
Vergleiche in unserer
In unserer
App ich habe hier ein
Firmenhandy und da ist so eine App von der
Personalabteilung drauf
Und da haben die immer ganz gut ganz witzige
Statistiken
Zum Gehalt und zwar
Kann ich das euch vorlesen
Dauert kurz bis der VPN Tunnel gestartet hat
Und alles
Also
Oh man jetzt mach halt mal hin
Kann sich das jetzt mal einloggen
Please
Ich glaube wir haben Wartungsarbeiten in unserer App
Die geht nicht auf
Ah doch jetzt
Also Vergütung
Mein Gehalt
Ah heute ist es so
Ich bekomme Gehalt umgerechnet
Lutscher im Monat
Ich
Das letzte Mal waren es Osterhasen
Heute
Heute sind es Lutscher
Ich glaube
Ich glaube das ist
Die wollen funny sein in der App
Das ist jeden Tag eine andere Statistik
Wie viel unser Gehalt in irgendwas umgerechnet ist
So okay
Und wenn ihr es in Zahlen wissen wollt
Okay
Wobei das erzähle ich jetzt nicht
Ich hab das schon öfters im Stream gesagt
So ungefähr
Kommen noch Leute um die Ecke
Und sagen ah der Max der muss uns das immer so aufs Auge drücken
Reicht wenn ich das ab und zu mal erwähne
Ja
Muss man sich jetzt mal drüber
Austauschen zumindest mehr als da
Aber das ist ja
Wirklich nix
Abgeschlossene IT Ausbildung
Lehre Kollege HTL
Sag doch einfach
Welche Tarifvertrag und welche Stufen in der IT realistisch sind
Keine Ahnung
Ich bin nicht im Tarifvertrag
Deutsche und die Scham über
Geld zu sprechen
Du kennst weder meine Videos noch bist du öfters im Stream
Wir hatten das schon so oft als Thema
Ich will es bloß nicht laufend allen immer
Auf die Nase binden immer wieder
Komme ich mir blöd bei vor
Wenn ich das jedes Mal erzähle und dann geht die Diskussion
Wieder los und nach dem Motto ja
Warum ist das so viel
Warum kriegt man dafür sowas
Und was muss man machen
Ich hab sogar Youtube Videos drüber gemacht
Wo ich den genauen Betrag jetzt erzählt habe
Genau
Max ist schon bald Millionär
Vor allem mit meinen Stonks Leute
Die Stonks sind ja die Woche richtig hoch gegangen
Und zwar ich habe diese Woche
Passt auf
Massive Stonks
Minus
Minus 2000 Euro
Knapp
Nix
Stonks
Aber
Meine Stonks sind ja kein wirklicher Verlust
Weil
Das wäre es ja erst wenn ich es verkaufe
Nvidia Stonks ging ab
Ich hab eh nur ETFs
Insofern ist es für mich egal
Ich lass das langfristig liegen
Weil ich so planlos bin was Investitionen angeht
Und auch keinen Bock habe mich damit zu beschäftigen
Ich bezahle einfach regelmäßig
Geld in ETFs
Bezahlen
Ja genau
Okay
Erfahrung in der Systemadministration
Hörerschein
Kenntnisse im Bereich Netzwerk Security
Einsatzbereitschaft
Innovationsfreude
Also ganz ehrlich für 31k im Jahr
Dann würde sich meine Einsatzbereitschaft
Echt in Grenzen halten
Freude an der Arbeit im Team
Problemlösungskompetenz
Zivildienst
Bei männlichen Bewerbern
Oh hier Racism
Nee Sexism
Warum nur bei Männern
Geleistete Präsenz
Na gut wahrscheinlich weil es die einzigen sind die das machen müssen
Aber trotzdem
Warum ist das wichtig
Ja doch es ist wichtig
Dass sie nicht auf einmal eingezogen werden zum Zivildienst
Während die dort anfangen
Macht schon Sinn
Darf man das aber überhaupt noch so schreiben
Wenn er sich gar nicht mehr als männlicher Bewerber
Überhaupt identifiziert dann ist die Anzeige
Direkt raus
Auf ihre Bewerbung freuen sich
Mark A. Dr. In
Was
Ist das irgendein Titel oder sind das Gänsefüßchen
Kommt da unten noch eine Erklärung
Mark A. Dr. In
Hacker
Verstehe ich nicht was das bedeuten soll
Ja aber wofür
Ist das der Bereich in dem die
Doktorin ihren Doktor gemacht hat
Achso
Das ist
Okay
Ich will mich jetzt nicht zu sehr über das Thema
Auflassen weil das immer ein ziemlich großes
Reizthema ist aber ich mein
Ernsthaft können wir uns
Vielleicht mal in irgendeiner Art und Weise dafür entscheiden
Ob wir jetzt Bewerber und Bewerberinnen
Schreiben ob wir Systemadministrator
Innen schreiben oder ob wir
Das dann so komisch schreiben ich mein irgendwie
Auf irgendwas einigen kann man sich doch
Dann sollen sie es
Zumindest mal halbwegs
Einheitlich warum muss das jetzt drei verschiedene
Schreibweisen haben
Da steige
Ich aus bei dem Thema
Ansonsten Hand habe ich sie
Bei vielem wer Bock drauf hat sollen sie
Machen soll bloß kein anderer damit auf den Sack gehen
Aber
Ist immer bisschen was einheitliches vielleicht
So Bewerbungsunterlagen
Also ganz ehrlich
Hier würde ich mich nicht bewerben weil ich die
Bezahlung nicht angemessen für das finde was man
Alles können und machen soll und das für mich
So wie nach einer klassischen Einmann
IT Abteilung und inklusive
Turnschuhadministration aussieht
Dass man nämlich auch noch zu irgendwelchen Standorten fahren darf
Und sowas
Also
Keine Ahnung das wäre nichts
Echt ich bin aber
Nicht über 50
Moins
Hier bald eine neue Wohnung
Und ohne Fritzbox wird es nicht mehr tun
Macht es Sinn
Mit einer zweiten Fritzbox was mit
Mesh zu versuchen oder ist sowas humbug
Und man sollte
Für was ausgeklügt
Also Mesh
Ist ja
Wirklich sinnvoll nur
Wenn die Mesh Teilnehmer also
Die Access Points selbst an einem
Kabel hängen so diese Mesh
Geschichte mit also
Du musst nicht aber so richtig sinnvoll
Ist es nur so diese Mesh
Geschichte mit wir stellen
Mehrere Access Points auf die dann
Untereinander über mehrere
Channels sich miteinander verbinden
Das kann man machen wenn man gar keine
Möglichkeit hat irgendwie
An irgendwelchen
Stellen WLAN zu bekommen das ist
Quasi die moderne Variante von WLAN
Extender wenn man so will
Aber so richtig so richtig sinnvoll
Ist das nur wenn beide Access
Points eben
Per Kabel am Netzwerk hängen
Und miteinander reden können
Der Vorteil davon ist dann dass du
Beispielsweise von einem zum
Anderen Access Point ohne Probleme wechseln
Kannst ohne Verbindungsabrisse und sowas
Das ist schon ganz nice
Aber ansonsten Kabel
Ist tatsächlich das Beste was es gibt
Aber ganz im Ernst
Je nachdem wie groß deine Wohnung ist
Sollte deine
Bestehende Fritzbox voll und ganz ausreichen
Wohnungen sind oftmals nur auf einer Ebene
Und
Jetzt auch nicht
400 Quadratmeter groß
Also wenn du WLAN willst
Solltest wahrscheinlich eine ganz normale Fritzbox
Auch tun
Und brauchst keine zweite
Ja es gibt leider
Sehr viele unfähige Manager und Führungskräfte
Die das nicht auf die
Reihe kriegen
Es gibt auch sehr viele unfähige
Techniker ich würde sagen
Das
Der weit überwiegende Teil
Aller Techniker eigentlich nichts kann
Und auch der weit überwiegende Teil
Aller Führungskräfte nichts kann
So richtig gut sind eh bloß 10%
Man muss halt
Ein Gefühl dafür haben
Ob man da einen vor sich hat
Oder nicht das ist ja unter anderem das was man
Auch versucht bei Vorstellungsgesprächen
Irgendwie rauszufinden ob man einen vor sich
Hat der ausnahmsweise mal was kann
Oder ob man ihn halt nur für irgendeine
Windows Wizard
Durchklickstelle benutzen
Verwenden kann
Und das muss man bei Führungskräften auch rauskriegen
Ob die ihren Job können oder nicht
Und der kann es ja anscheinend nicht bei euch
Das dachte ich mir bei der Stellenanzeige auch
Du musst sicherlich noch
VBA und Excel mitmachen hierbei
Ja garantiert
Musst hier noch VBA und Excel mitmachen
Das liest sich schon so
Ich glaube nicht
Dass die Löhne in Österreich so viel
Geringer sind als bei uns
Ja wahrscheinlich
Nee warum
IT Leute sind begehrt
Man muss sich heute nicht mehr unter Wert
Verkaufen
Was ist denn HTL das ist irgendeine
Höhere
Technische
Leistung nee keine Ahnung
Das ist so ein Österreicher Ding
Ich hab aktuell noch ein
Verfahren für einen Admin offen
Was ein Verfahren du meinst also Bewerbungsverfahren
Wo ich mir in 3 Wochen
Die Bewerber im Gespräch ansehe
Oh du bist der Chef ja schick her
Magst du dir die Ausschreibung
Ja ja schick her
Also du willst es ja wahrscheinlich von mir wissen
So nach dem Motto würde man sich
Darauf bewerben oder nicht
Haben wir hier schon ein paar mal gemacht
Ich bekomme sogar mittlerweile
Es ist eigentlich lustig
Ich bekomme mittlerweile sogar schon Anfragen
An meine Business E-Mail
Ob ich mir
Einen T-Shirt kaufen könnte
Und einer hat dann
Hat er auch mal geschrieben
Wenn ich das mache würde ich auch
Ein kostenloses T-Shirt und Kappe
Von ihnen bekommen
Merchandising
Ich hab's mir angeguckt aber ich wollte kein Merchandise haben
Nee ist nix dabei
Wahrscheinlich weil man zu irgendwelchen
Außendienststellen fahren muss wenn was kaputt ist
Ja mich auch nicht
Ich glaube das ist
Klar geworden dass sie mich auch nicht umhaut
Ah ne danke für den Sub
Brock
Ich hab den einen ja sogar geschrieben
Ähm
Wenn sie noch weitere Infos
Also weiteres Consulting wollen
Können sie sich an meinen Manager wenden
Wollten sie dann nicht
Die denken bei mir oder nichts
Okay
Nein nein ich melde mich hier nicht an
Also
Interne Stellenausschreibung
Im Dezernaten
Das hört sich ja fast schon nach Polizei an
Abteilung 37
Feuer- und Katastrophenschutz ist eine volle
Oh das klingt auch tatsächlich als hat man da ein bisschen
Verantwortung bei
Feuer- und Katastrophenschutz ist eine volle
Stelle als Systemadministrator
Für die integrierte
Kreisleitstelle in Söst
Ist das auch AT?
Oder?
Wo ist denn Söst? Ist das in Deutschland?
Oder ist das in Österreich oder in der Schweiz? Ich hab keine Ahnung
NRW okay
Der Feuerwehr und das Katastrophenschutz
Dazu gehören 11 Wachen für den Rettungsdienst
Bereits eingeschlossen
Eine hauptamtliche Betriebe
Die gerade befinden sich im Rettungsdienst
Alles klar
Gut das heißt wahrscheinlich die wollen auch dass man zu den unterschiedlichen
Stellen hin und her fährt würde ich da jetzt mal so rein
Interpretieren dass man nicht nur
Quasi den ganzen Tag am Computer bei sich hockt
Sondern wenn dort vor Ort was ist muss man da wahrscheinlich auch hinfahren
Zumindest würde ich das ja mal so rein interpretieren
Wenn ich das jetzt zum ersten Mal so
Als potenzieller Bewerber sehen würde
Ihr Aufgabenbereich umfasst im wesentlichen
Durchführen der Systemadministration
Der IT und Kommunikationssysteme
Der Leitstelle inklusive deren Schnittstellen
Gut ja gut
Hätte ich jetzt auch erwartet ich meine es ist relativ
Unspezifisch da kann man sich jetzt nichts wirklich drunter
Vorstellen
Die technische Betreuung der Anwender
In der Leitstelle inklusive Schulung und
Fehlermanagement
Das heißt auch du bist sowas wie
Support
Da hätte ich jetzt ja persönlich
Schon relativ wenig Bock drauf
Instandhaltung der zentralen
Server und Netzwerk basierenden Dienste und
Fachanwendungen
Ja kümmerst dich halt um die Kisten
Ja ok
Leuchtet ein technische Sicherstellung
Der ständigen Systemverfügbarkeit der
Leitstelle als kritische Infrastruktur
Auch klar
Unterstützung in der vorhandenen Stelle
Digitalfunk
Programmierung von
Funkgeräten nach Vorgaben von Behörden
Pflege und Anlage von
Orts- und Objektdatenalarm und
Ausrückungsordnung
Jetzt hätte ich gar keine Ahnung
Was ihr von mir wollt an der Stelle
Wahrscheinlich geht es
Darum dass man in irgendeinem UI in der
Datenbank was hinterlegt
Das würde ich nicht verstehen was ich hier machen soll
Umsetzung von Automatisierung
Verfahren
Systemadministration
IT der Einsatzfahrzeuge
Weiterentwicklung
Erweiterung der eingesetzten technischen Lösungen
Das ist äußerst
Vage
Das kann ja auch alles und nichts bedeuten
Weiterentwicklung, Optimierung und Erweiterung
der eingesetzten technischen Lösungen
Das ist wirklich alles und nichts
Durchführung von Projekten zur Einführung
von neuen und ergänzenden
Das Anfertigen und Aktualisieren
Fortschreiben
Wie macht ihr etwa Fehler?
Ich dachte nur wenn man Fehler macht, braucht man Dokumentation
Gut
Gehört zum Job dabei
Verstehe ich
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde es vielleicht nicht so prominent reinschreiben
Weil im Endeffekt ist jedem klar, dass er es machen muss
Aber keiner macht es gerne
Aber es ist nicht
verkehrt, es schreiben viele rein
So, Ausbildung als Physi-
Umfangreicher an Erkenntnissen der Netzwerktechnik
Server-Anwendungs-Virtualisierung
vor allem bei Citrix
Wow, jetzt geht es aber los
Umverreichung anwendbarer Kenntnisse in Windows und Linux
Betriebssystemen, Datenbank
Anwendungskenntnisse im Bereich Kommunikation
Das ist aber ganz schön viel
Praktische und theoretische
Grundkenntnisse
Was? Moment
Praktische und theoretische Grundkenntnisse in der
nicht polizeilichen Gefahrenabwehr
Okay, da würde ich aussteigen
Keine Ahnung
Aber gut, jemand der das hat, weiß wahrscheinlich was gemeint ist
Erweiterte praktische und theoretische
Grundkenntnisse
Okay, keine Ahnung
Ausgeprägte, belastbar, kein Stress
Das finde ich in dem
Okay, normalerweise würde ich sagen
Warum schreibt ihr sowas rein?
Hier geht es doch nicht um Leben und Tod
Hier muss ich sagen, da würde ich mal eine Ausnahme machen
Weil, ich vermute mal an der Stelle
Geht es eventuell doch mal
um Leben und Tod, also das ist ja schon in Ordnung
Ich finde es immer lustig, wenn das
Bei irgendwelchen 0815
Sesselfurzer Jobs dabei steht
Und man sich dann denkt, ey okay
Dann geht es halt mal kaputt und was passiert schon?
Aber hier passiert wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr, wenn es wirklich kaputt ist
Ein Einfühlvermögen
Okay, das ist auch mal selten
Dass sowas in der Physi- bzw.
IT-Stellenanzeige
drinsteht
Warum? Warum braucht man ein hohes
Maß an Einfühlungsvermögen? Ich meine
Mit irgendwelchen Opfern
Oder, ja, keine Ahnung
Mit Leuten, wo das Haus abgefackelt ist oder so
Wird man ja wahrscheinlich nicht interagieren, oder?
Also man braucht jetzt da nicht
Irgendwie einen
Grundkurs in
Was auch immer man da so braucht
Teamfähigkeit, Teamgeist, eine lösungsorientierte Denkweise
sowie Einsatz
Die Bereitschaft
Okay, Bereitschaft ist auch ein bisschen dabei
Ja, verstehe ich
Wir bieten ihnen Beschäftigung
Das dachte ich mir, er sucht ja auch jemand
Oh, das ist glaube ich nicht sonderlich viel, oder?
Ich habe mir das mal irgendwann
angeguckt, aber wobei
Das Maximum geht schon ganz gut
Klar
Also wahrscheinlich, okay, sagen wir mal
Du fängst mit
Okay
Sagen wir mal, du fängst mit ungefähr 4000 Euro im Monat an
Ich weiß nicht, ob das realistisch ist, mal 12
Äh, nicht Minus
So super viel ist das
jetzt auch nicht, in der heutigen Zeit
Mal 13, okay, dann sieht es besser aus
Ja, ich denke, da werdet ihr
ein paar Bewerber auf jeden Fall finden
Aber, sagen wir mal so, üppig ist
was anderes
Ein interessantes Abwechslung
Zumal sich der Kram ja auch erhöht mit der Zeit
Irgendwann hat man dann auch mal Fütter
Ich meine, reich
wirst du nicht
Aber du bewegst dich schon in ungefähr ein paar
Regionen vielleicht, wo man sich denkt, okay
Da kann man sich mal überlegen
Ein interessantes Abwechslung
Ja, also
Telefonlieger
Du sollst dich ja auch bewerben
Ach, Zusammenarbeit in Stresssituationen
Ein Feuerwehrmann,
der im Stress ist
Okay, das ist schon
Das ist eine sehr, wie soll ich sagen
eine sehr
verantwortungsvolle und ich würde auch sagen
eine anspruchsvolle
Stelle
In Bereichen anspruchsvoll
die ich jetzt
normalerweise von einem IT-Systemadministrator
so nicht erwarten würde
und auch nicht erwarten kann
Also, ihr sucht ganz spezielle Leute
Also, nur weil jemand IT
Alter, ich muss was trinken
Jet Gear, warum erinnert mich keiner
Ja, also
das erscheint mir wirklich
anspruchsvoll zu sein
Gerade in Bereichen, die man
nicht so
häufig bei IT-Leuten
jetzt unbedingt hat
Ich meine, die wenigsten IT-Leute sind super einfühlsam
Und
Ja
Das muss schon jemand
Spezielles sein, der sich da drauf bewirbt
Ich denke mir halt
Ihr werdet wahrscheinlich Schwierigkeiten haben
jemanden zu finden, der das abdeckt
Weil
das nicht nur ein
relativ breit gefächertes
Technik
Anspruch ist, den ihr hier habt
Ich meine, da ist ja wirklich sehr viel
unterschiedliches Zeug drin
Noch dazu wollt ihr einige Sachen, die halt jetzt
sagen wir mal so
härter sind in der Anforderung
wie bei anderen Jobs
Und auch ein paar Sachen, wo man sagen würde
die findet man bei IT-Leuten
vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger
Das heißt, ich könnte mir fast vorstellen
für das Geld
wird es vielleicht nicht der Wunschkandidat werden
Aber wenn man dann
auch ein bisschen bereit ist
die Leute ordentlich einzuarbeiten und ein bisschen
Abstriche zu machen, denke ich, wird es schon die einen oder anderen
Bewerber geben. Ansonsten
Also aus meiner persönlichen Meinung
ist die Stellenanzeige ein bisschen zu lang
Man könnte, denke ich, vieles hier
zusammenfassen, ja das mit
Flexibilität und Team...
Manche Sachen muss man
finde ich gar nicht großartig
reinschreiben
Also Teamfähigkeit und vielleicht
da könnte man eins machen
und
ich würde es allgemein irgendwie
ein bisschen kürzen, das erscheint mir
erschien mir jetzt beim
lesen alles ein bisschen lang
und aufgesplittet
Trotzdem, aber zu den
technischen Sachen kann ich sagen, das ist ziemlich
ziemlich heftig, was ihr eigentlich
haben wollt, weil
ich meine
es geht um Netzwerktechnik
es geht um Server und Virtualisierung
für MWare und Citrix
es geht um Windows und Linux
Datenbank und VoIP
und seriously, VoIP
ordentlich VoIP und SIP und Sachen zu können ist komplette
Wissenschaft für sich
Also das ist schon, das ist wirklich
ein sehr, also
vielleicht ist euch das beim Schreiben
nicht so aufgefallen, weil das eben so euer täglich
täglich Brot hier ist, aber das in Kombination
ist tatsächlich gar nicht ohne
So, dann kommt Bereitschafts
Willen und so noch dazu
Also ich fürchte, den Wunschkandidaten werdet
ihr für die Bezahlung nicht finden
und man könnte die Stellenanzeige wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
kurz und knackiger schreiben
Aber ansonsten müsste ich es mir nochmal im Detail angucken
Also ich würde mich nicht
bewerben
Okay, also ich
würde mich nicht bewerben aus den Gründen
aus den Gründen, die ich eben genannt habe, also ich finde
also ich habe keinen Bock auf
irgendwelche
Bereitschaftssachen, Notrufsachen am Wochenende
die
durchaus eintreten können in dem
Fall. Ich meine, dort
wo ich jetzt bin, da haben wir auch sowas wie
sei mal
erreichbar von dann und dann am Samstag, aber
da wirst du halt alle fünf Jahre einmal
angerufen oder so
Aber das könnte ich mir schon, gerade wenn es um Feuerwehr
und sowas geht, schon öfters vorstellen
Ich hätte auch
keinen Bock auf
die, wie soll ich sagen,
auf die
Verantwortung, kann man es vielleicht ausdrücken
wenn ich quasi
Also es ist ein Unterschied
Es ist ein Unterschied, ob
dich jemand anruft und sagt
Ey, unser Server ist kaputt
ähm, der Außendienst
kann gerade keine Verträge verkaufen
oder ob mich ein Feuerwehrmann anruft
oder ein Krankenwagen
und sagt, der Server
ist kaputt und sterben hier gerade fünf Leute
Also, ja, übertrieben gesagt
Da hätte ich persönlich keinen Bock drauf
Dass ich in irgendeiner Art und Weise
für verantwortlich bin
dass Leute abkratzen könnten, wenn ich
nicht schnell genug den Server fixe
Das wäre es mir nicht wert
ehrlich gesagt, also
das würde ich nicht machen wollen
Man könnte vielleicht noch ein bisschen konkreter reinschreiben
mit welchen Technologien gearbeitet wird
Netzwerk ist ziemlich 0815
Windows, Linux
ist auch sehr 0815, da wäre vielleicht ganz interessant
was da genau gemacht wird
Datenbank ist auch sehr 0815
Datenbank zum Beispiel
Ja
So sieht es aus
Ich fange nicht an
als Konsultant
Es kommt immer drauf an
Branche, Region, wo man unterwegs ist
Wenn du jetzt irgendwo im Osten bist
Irgendwo in, keine Ahnung, Leipzig oder so
oder irgendwie noch besser
Leipziger Umland oder so, ist das sicherlich
sicherlich okay
Ich kann euch mal meine
Ansicht der Dinge sagen
Also ich rede jetzt von Frankfurter
oder sagen wir mal hessischer
Frankfurter Finanzbranche
IT mäßig
Ich würde es
wahrscheinlich nicht unter
Also es kommt halt ein bisschen auf die
Stelle an, weil
wenn es jetzt mein absoluter
Traumjob ist, also gehen wir mal
davon aus, ich finde den absoluten
Traumjob so, genau das
was ich machen will, hundertprozentig
passend und auch wenig
Bürokratie und alles so
Da würde ich sagen so
ab 80k kann man da
vielleicht drüber reden, wobei
ich es halt mal
messen würde auch am aktuellen
Job, der ist jetzt
nicht so schlecht
Ist vielleicht nicht gerade durch die Bürokratie
nicht hundertprozentig mein Traumjob, aber
vom Inhalt her ist es echt ziemlich
gut und da ist es halt noch mal
eine ganze Ecke mehr, also
wahrscheinlich würde ich unter 80k
auch nichts machen mehr
Ich muss mal kurz
die Fernbedienung für meine
Klimaanlage holen, hier wird es zu warm
So
Hier ist nämlich gerade über 28 Grad
drin, bis sie kühlen
Okay
Trinken erinnern, gut mach ich mal
Für das was von der Technik
also
dann sag ich es jetzt doch
um das mal ins Verhältnis zu setzen
Also
Wo ist denn
hier meine Vergütung
Alter, warum ist diese
App so schlecht
Okay, also
80% Teilzeit
bekomme ich aktuell
Brutto im Monat
aufgerundet
Netto sind das
ungefähr 3300
So, da kommt aber noch dabei
ein Bonus
und
wenn Rufbereitschaft ist
Rufbereitschaft, also ich würde sagen
da kommt noch mal so ungefähr
schwer zu sagen
15% oder so
noch mal drauf, so über Daumen gepeilt
So
Also sprich, ich verdiene schon
Base-Gehalt ohne Bonus und sonstige
Zulagen bei
80% mehr als man hier maximal
verdienen könnte. Ich weiß, dass
das nicht und deswegen sag ich das jetzt auch in letzter Zeit
so ungern. Ich weiß, dass jetzt wieder die Leute
anfangen und sagen, ja, aber das kann man. Nein, kann man
auch nicht. Das ist Frankfurter
Finanzbranche, die händeringend Leute
sucht und exakt das
gesucht hat, was von meinen Skills her passt. Also
das ist jetzt bestimmt nicht
der Normalfall, aber
einfach mal um es ins Verhältnis zu setzen,
dass man mit 80%
und bei weitem nicht so viel
Verantwortung
und Teilzeit mehr bekommt
13 Jahre oder 15 Jahre Erfahrung
Ja, was glaube ich auch eines der Probleme
ist, warum man in Behörden, warum die
Behörden so schlecht Leute finden
Ja, ist doch nice. Ich finde es gut,
dass sich da Leute drauf bewerben, vor allem wenn das welche
sind, die nicht so wie ich drauf
sind, dass die keinen Bock auf die Verantwortung haben
Ja, eigentlich ist die Stelle
tatsächlich auch nicht nur einer
Das stimmt
Tom sagt, hat man mit einem Kollegen darüber geredet
das vorher Frankfurt, der meinte
aber auch, dass man Frankfurt nicht wirklich mit anderen Umgebungen
vergleichen kann. Ja, das ist so
Jaja, das sage ich ja auch immer dabei
Das Ding ist halt, guckt mal
Wenn jetzt ein
künftiger
Arbeitgeber
zu mir kommt und sagt, Max, wir bieten
dir das, das und das und die und die Kohle
und das ist halt ordentlich
dann werde ich ja wohl nicht hingehen
und sagen, ach ne
ähm
bezahlt mir mal ein bisschen weniger
Warum sollte man das
machen, wenn man die Möglichkeiten hat?
Würde wahrscheinlich jeder so machen
und in Frankfurt ist halt dieses, wir bezahlen
dir mal ordentlich was, halt auch wirklich
ordentlich. Muss man halt, muss man sagen, Frankfurt, der Finanzbranche
ist da echt bereit, ordentlich
Asche in die Hand zu nehmen, um fähige Leute zu
bekommen und man muss halt auch sagen,
der Job passt auch wunderbar
wirklich gut zu meinen Skills
Es ist halt auch nicht alltäglich, dass man
was hat, was so gut zusammenpasst
Die haben ja auch was von
Und
ich hab letztens so ne, wobei das erzähl ich
gleich, wenn wir hier unten bei dem anderen kommen sind
Genau, ganz
ehrlich, was dieser Job safe hat, ist
ein Sinn. Die Chance, dass man sich erfüllt
fühlt, ist sehr hoch. Ja, das denk ich auch
Ich hab aber
letztens so ne Tabelle ausgefüllt, wo
es drum ging, was ist einem besonders
wichtig im Job
Und bei mir war, glaub ich, der letzte
Punkt von allen, ich weiß nicht, haben wir das irgendwo noch?
Ich glaub, das haben wir nicht gespeichert, oder?
Nee, ich glaub, das haben wir nicht
gespeichert
Der letzte und unwichtigste
Punkt bei mir war, dass mein
Job einen Sinn für die Menschheit hat
Hab ich gespeichert?
Wo?
Du weißt, dass bei...
Nee, hab ich nicht gespeichert, sonst wäre
das hier irgendwo drin
Oder war das in Visual Studio?
Codename hab ich hier gar nicht
Nee, das ist...
In der VM?
Hab das nicht gespeichert
Nö, da habt ihr euch
verguckt
Zumindest hab ich letztens so ne
Tabelle ausgefüllt, wo es darum ging, was einem
wichtig ist, so Sicherheit im Job
Gehalt im Job
Verwirklichungsdinger
im Job und sowas
Und tatsächlich, der unwichtigste Punkt bei mir
im Job war, dass mein Job
einen Sinn für die Menschheit hat, das war mir ziemlich egal
Naja, was wir intern benutzen,
werde ich hier nicht öffentlich auf Twitch erzählen
Wie ist das
mit der Wohnsituation in Frankfurt?
Wie schnell findet man eine Wohnung? Wie viel kostet die?
Wenn du genug Geld hast, findest du
easy ne Wohnung
Es gab
paar Straßen weiter von meinem alten Arbeitgeber
gab es so
Apartments, das war so gefühlt so ein halbes
naja
so ein halber Teil von der Hausetage
war das, auch übelst gut ausgestattet
und so, da hast du glaub ich 12.000 Euro
im Monat für bezahlen müssen
und die waren eigentlich
immer sofort zu haben
war auch riesengroß
aber komischerweise
wollte kaum jemand haben
ansonsten, normale Wohnungen in Frankfurt
ich weiß es nicht, ich wohne ja nicht direkt
in Frankfurt, ich wohne ja hier im Umland
und fahr nach Frankfurt rein
und nachdem ich
auch nicht zur Miete mehr wohne
weiß ich nicht, wie das aktuell
so ist
Ja, das kann man aber denke ich trennen, also ich brauche
keinen Sinn für die Menschheit, es geht mir genauso
Ich brauche keinen Sinn für die Menschheit
in meinem Job, aber
man sollte schon irgendwie Progress sehen
Ja, das sehe ich auch so
Ich hatte übrigens letzte Woche wieder
einen Big Brain Moment
und zwar
Ich bin gerade
an einem Projekt beteiligt auf der Arbeit
wo es um
Blockchain Sachen geht
Bitcoin und solche
Geschichten
Irgendjemand kam auf die
glorreiche Idee, ich muss das ja so ein bisschen
umschreiben, dass ich nicht so viel verrate
aber das an sich
ist nichts Geheimes
Irgendjemand kam auf die glorreiche Idee
warum lassen wir
nicht einen Polygon
Polygon Node in
Kubernetes laufen und wenn man
sich mal im Internet so umguckt
also Polygon ist auch irgendwie so eine Blockchain
Gedöns
und wenn man sich
im Internet mal umguckt, wird man feststellen
okay, irgendwie lässt den Kram
niemand in Kubernetes laufen
Du findest so gut wie nichts
wenn du nach Polygon und Kubernetes
suchst an Beispielen
Ich meine, es gibt aber genug Beispiele für Docker
Also habe ich mich
letzte Woche hingesetzt, obwohl
das eigentlich nicht meine primäre Aufgabe ist
aber im Projekt passt das eigentlich ganz gut
und habe ein
Helmchart gebaut zum Installieren
von einem Polygon Node in Kubernetes
sprich dazu gehören die eigentlichen
frag mich nicht wie das heißt
die eigentlichen
Blockchain
Sachen und dann die
frag mich nicht
Blockchain Spezialbegriffe
man braucht zwei Teile für so eine Blockchain
man braucht irgendwie einen Execution Layer
und einen
ich hab vergessen wie es heißt, man braucht verschiedene Sachen
also im Prinzip sind es nur zwei verschiedene
Container, die man zum Laufen bringen muss
für Polygon, allerdings ist die
Config nicht so einfach
Polygon ist eine Blockchain
Krypto-Krempel
und Polygon ist irgendwie so eine Art
Meta-Blockchain
die mehr als
genau, Matic ist die eigentliche
quasi die Native Währung von
Polygon, allerdings Polygon
selbst kann wohl auch
Ethereum und noch
andere Blockchain Sachen
Keine Ahnung, ich hab von der Blockchain Geschichte nicht wirklich
großartig planen, ich hab bloß dafür gesorgt
dass man die Sachen in Kubernetes installieren kann
das hab ich innerhalb von einem Tag
in ein funktionierendes Helmchart zusammengewurstelt
mit
Customizable Netzwerk
und allem und die Config war tatsächlich gar nicht so
einfach und ich hab
festgestellt, was ich in einem Tag
da zusammengewurstelt hab, gab es
vorher einen Dienstleister, der das machen soll
also warum ich das gemacht hab, ist
der Grund ist ganz einfach, wir haben jemand
der ist dafür zuständig, der ist jetzt aber seit drei Wochen
krank und ich hab gesagt, ich kann doch mal gucken
so schwierig kann es doch nicht sein, so ein paar
Container ins Helmchart zu packen
und er kann ja nächste
Woche da weitermachen
und da habt ihr es mal angefangen
wir hatten davor einen Dienstleister
der hat ein halbes Jahr
das nicht auf die Reihe bekommen
der hat ein halbes Jahr daran gebaut
und hat nichts
fertig bekommen und ich hab das einfach
mal in einem Tag hingewurschtelt
das soll jetzt nicht bedeuten, dass ich
der Ultra-Giga-Brain
ever bin, weil so schwierig
war das Ganze gar nicht, also wer schon mal
ein Kubernetes
Helmchart gebaut hat oder auch
ein Kubernetes Jammels gebaut hat
der weiß, dass wenn man
eine Anleitung für Docker hat
dann weiß man schon die Images
und weiß die Option, so schwer
ist das nicht
kompliziert wird es dann mit der Custom-Config
wie man die haben will, aber so schwer ist
das nicht, aber der Dienstleister hat halt auch
wieder ein halbes Jahr Geld eingesackt und nichts gemacht
das war mein
Giga-Brain-Moment
letzte Woche wieder
und ich hab von meinem alten Arbeitgeber
was gelernt und das ist was
das kann ich euch auch nur empfehlen
ich hab da eine Weile für gebraucht und zwar
Leute, wenn ihr was
gemacht habt
wenn ihr irgendwas, also auf der Arbeit
wenn ihr irgendwas auf der Arbeit gemacht habt
was Gutes oder was Schlaues
rausgefunden habt oder irgendwas gefixt habt
dann
tretet das ein bisschen breit
labert ein bisschen drüber
ihr müsst nicht gleich sagen
hallo, äh, Vorstand, ich würde euch gerne was
präsentieren, dann müsst ihr nicht übertreiben
aber tretet das ruhig ein bisschen breit
das hab ich von meinem alten Arbeitgeber gelernt
es ist sehr nützlich dafür
für die Wahrnehmung
und auch für spätere Gehaltsverhandlungen
wenn die Dinger, die man
gemacht hat, auch an den richtigen Stellen
angekommen sind und wenn ihr Sachen einfach
nur macht, egal wie 5Head und
BigBrain die sind, wenn
ihr die einfach macht und dann nie wieder ein Wort
drüber verliert, dann merkt das keiner
das heißt, ihr müsst was
Gutes machen, genau, sowas
in der Richtung, ihr müsst was Gutes machen
und das dann auch ein bisschen
erzählen, ein bisschen breit treten
und
ja, ich hab mir
extra schon, damit ich's nicht vergesse
so für die Zukunft, ich hab mir auch extra schon ein
Textdokument angelegt, für alle
5Head-Aktionen hab ich mir ein Textdokument
gemacht, wo ich mir das stichpunktartig
aufschreibe
und wenn ich den nächsten Termin mit
meinem Chef hab, gibt's dann hier alle 5Head-Aktionen
aufgelistet
Dominik, Dankeschön für den Sub
man darf's auch nicht überübertreiben
McFly, Dankeschön für den Sub
aber das ist tatsächlich was
ähm
das hab ich eine Weile
für gebraucht, das zu lernen
aber es ist so
ihr könnt noch so viele geile Sachen auf der Arbeit machen
wenn ihr danach
nicht drüber redet, wird's keiner richtig mitbekommen
es bekommt vielleicht euer Chef mit und wisst ihr
was das Schlimmste ist, irgendwann
nimmt man es als selbstverständlich an
dass ihr
alle high IQ komplizierten Sachen
ohne Probleme auf die Reihe bekommt
das heißt es ist sogar für euch schädlich
wenn ihr zu oft am Stück
Probleme löst, die sonst keiner lösen kann
dann denkt man immer, ach das macht der doch easy
GreenOnScreen, Danke für den Sub
es ist besser
wenn ihr was kompliziertes macht und dann auch mal
alle wissen lasst, wie kompliziert das gewesen ist
wie gesagt, ich sag nicht
dass ihr in den E-Mail an den Vorstand schreiben sollt
und sagen, hier guck mal was ich geiles gemacht hab
nee, das nicht unbedingt, aber zum Beispiel
was man durchaus machen kann ist
ähm
mit seinem Chef drüber reden, wenn man
eine Teamrunde hat, drüber reden
oder wenn man irgendwelche
Dailies oder Status-Meetings von irgendeinem Projekt hat
mal kurz so 2-3 Sachen zeigen
was man gemacht hat
und man kann da durchaus auch ein bisschen
ich nenns mal
so das Standard ITler jammern machen
so nach dem Motto, und das sah ja erst ganz
einfach aus, aber Leute, ich sag euch, natürlich
war es nicht einfach, ich hab da ganz schön mit
gekämpft, aber nach ner Woche hab ichs hingekriegt
also
macht nix, ja, es ist
sogar besser, als einfach die Sachen zu machen
und die Klappe zu halten
ich denke das ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert
es ist schon die Aufgabe einer Führungskraft
sagen wir mal
mitzubekommen, was die Leute so
so Gutes treiben und
das auch gut zu verkaufen, allerdings
kann man von denen ja auch nicht erwarten
dass wenn du nix davon hörst
und siehst, es mitzubekommen
wie sollen sie das machen, ja
also, da müssten die ja
über jedes Problem Bescheid wissen
wissen, wie kompliziert und wie
Zähne ausbeißen sich die Leute an dem Problem
und dass sie das dann gefixt hat
können die ja gar nicht alles im Detail mitbekommen
ja, irgendwo ist es schon ihre Aufgabe
das bei größeren Sachen mitzubekommen, aber
es ist ja gar nicht möglich
dementsprechend, damit sie ihre Aufgabe wahrnehmen
können, ist nicht
verkehrt, wenn man ab und zu mal auch
seinem Chef über aktuelle Sachen
Ereignisse spricht und auch mal erzählt
ey guck mal, haben wir uns dran gesetzt, haben wir
hingekriegt in zwei Tagen, Dienstleister saß
dann ein halbes Jahr dran und solche Geschichten
das ist nicht
verkehrt, die meisten Führungskräfte
können das nicht
ja, ist so
ich würde aber auch so weit gehen
sagen, dass viele Techniker es auch nicht wirklich
drauf haben, aber
es gibt auch sehr viele Führungskräfte, die du komplett vergessen
kannst in der Rolle
und weiterer Tipp ist
noch, schreibt euch das mal irgendwie auf
weil ihr wisst das in einem halben Jahr oder so
auch nicht mehr und vielleicht müsst ihr es
in einem halben Jahr wissen, weil es gerade darum ging, was
tolles gelaufen ist und sowas
schreibt euch so Sachen immer auf, wenn ihr irgendwas
cooles gemacht habt, schreibt es euch einfach so kurz auf
zwei, drei Sätze
und dann
dann ist gut
so, eine Sache müssen wir uns
jetzt noch angucken
Github Trends, gucken wir uns nämlich immer an Sonntags
und ich bin schon zwei Stunden on, wir haben
nichts außer geschwätzt, top, nice Aufwachen
Stream, so was haben wir denn hier
Trending, diese Woche, Github
wir gucken uns keine AI-Geschichten
an, die skippen wir einfach
AI, AI, das heißt sogar schon AI
da muss ich nicht mal raten, was es ist
AI, AI
Mac-Editor juckt mich nicht, AI
AI, äh, ach Github
so ein Schwachsinn, alter
alles Noobs, die das verwenden
hier, alles, 17.700
Noobs, mindestens
wer verwendet Github Desktop von euch, Chat?
Timeout ist raus
nee, ernsthaft, verwendet jemand von euch
Github
Github Desktop?
ok, es verwenden Github Desktop, warum
verwendet ihr Github Desktop und nicht Github CLI
äh, äh, Gith CLI
richtig
richtig cringe, wer das benutzt
nee, ernsthaft, ich versteh's nicht, also
es soll ja jeder benutzen
die Tools, auf die er Bock hat
und mit denen er gut arbeiten kann
aber ich verstehe den Anwendungszweck von
diesen Tools nicht
Github CLI ist einfach das Beste, was es gibt
äh, Github, was laber ich denn?
Git, auf der Kommandozeile, ist einfach das Beste, was es gibt
da weiß man wenigstens, was passiert
und was es macht
ich hab übrigens mich auf der Arbeit dazu
bereit erklärt, mal so ein Git-Overview
für alle Git-Noobs zu machen
und ich bin mir unschlüssig, was ich dazu
reinschreiben soll, also was ich da
alles machen soll
ich glaub, man muss zwei
Termine machen
einmal
Basic und dann bisschen
Tipps und Tricks, so
magst du machen eine PowerPoint?
Ich kann auch keine PowerPoint machen
vielleicht ein bisschen
Übersicht, aber die eigentlichen Sachen muss man ja zeigen
äh
äh, AI
AI
AI, AI
äh, nee, Photo Hosting App
die ist tatsächlich ganz gut
AI, AI
AI, ah, Svelte trendet
nice, Svelte 4 ist übrigens rausgekommen
letztens
hat aber nicht sonderlich viele spannende Neuerungen
Elektron
äh, AI
Debug, Stelz
AI, AI
nicht sonderlich
viel spannendes, wow, nicht sonderlich viel
spannendes dabei
ja, ist das Beste
Git-Command Line, da weiß man
wenigstens, was passiert, ich hatte mal
ein Ex-Kollege, der hat
Eclipse verwendet
also allein schon
das ist ziemlich
aber es gibt Leute, die verwenden
ernsthaft Eclipse
und der hat das E-Git
was übrigens sehr guten Namen hat
E-Git Plugin verwendet
für Eclipse
und der hat immer wieder
leere Sachen committet
weil dieses Plugin einfach nur abgrundtief
schlecht war
der hat immer leere, der hat
übertrieben, immer mal wieder halt
leere Commits erstellt und sowas
das kannst du vergessen
das einzige, wie man Git ordentlich bedienen kann
und da bin ich wirklich überzeugt von
dass es so ist, ich hab noch kein
kein Plugin gesehen, was in die Nähe
kommt
Git-Command Line
das ist das einzige, was du
ordentlich benutzen kannst
ABAP
ist auch alles Mist
alles Mist
Kommando-Zeile-Git ist das Beste
naja gut
ja, mach ich, mach ich
aber dazu muss ich mir erst
was überlegen
ja, gibt's heute wieder
was haben wir denn schönes
was können wir uns denn jetzt mal auf YouTube noch angucken
Lost Places Europaturm in Frankfurt
oh, was ist das denn
The Truth About C++
das ist das richtige Video für mich
das scheint das richtige Video zu sein
3 Minuten, okay
das können wir uns angucken
das ist genau das richtige Video für mich jetzt
das Problem ist nur
wahrscheinlich laber ich eine Viertelstunde über 3 Minuten Video
was hätten wir denn sonst noch
zur Alternative
dieses Windows ist kein Linux
nee, dieses Windows ist ein Linux
PHP
okay
let's go
ich will die Wahrheit über C++ erfahren, Leute
Should you even learn C++?
See with Classes
Classes, later renamed to C++, was invented by
Jarnay Stroustrup in 1990
The more general aim was to design a language
in which I could write programs
that were both efficient and elegant
Many languages forced you to choose between the two alternatives
Since the initial release of the language
C++ has grown substantially
while adhering to three core
Ja, und nicht unbedingt
immer sonderlich konsistent und zum Besten
ich mein, passt mal auf
nee, was war das
was war das, was wir uns letztens
für eine Seite angeguckt haben
ich hab's schon wieder vergessen
oh, guck mal, sogar mein Browser ist defekt jetzt
nein, nein, wir hören jetzt auf
wir gucken uns einfach das Video an
oder wo hatten wir das
hatten wir das hier irgendwo
wir hatten so ein richtig schönes Beispiel dafür
äh, wo ist denn hier Verlauf
das hier
das ist gültiges C++, Leute
und wisst ihr, wisst ihr
was es noch schlimmer macht
das ist quasi, naja, offiziell
ich weiß nicht, ob's die offizielle Dokumentation ist
aber irgendjemand hat sich gedacht
das ist das beste Beispiel
für dieses Feature
und das ist die beste Formatierung
und beste Präsentation für dieses Feature
also es ist nicht einfach nur schlechtes C++
das ist eine Dokuseite
wo sich jemand überlegt hat
das ist die beste Art und Weise
es darzustellen
ja, stimmt auch
aber es ist halt auch objektiv gesehen unlesbar
noch nicht mal krassen C++
Kenner können das gut lesen
guckt euch das mal an
vor allem, vor allem
Standard ist trivially destructible
of T, alles klar
C++
das stimmt ja auch nur
wenn du durchblickst
wie von den tausend Varianten
man es jetzt, sag mal, korrekt benutzt
das stimmt ja auch nur
wenn du durchblickst
wie von den tausend Varianten
man es jetzt, sag mal, korrekt benutzt
Abstractions come at near zero cost
the most noticeable difference
between C and C++ to the beginner
is the inclusion of objects
Structs in C are just memory
organized in a particular order
Objects in C++ have methods
constructors and deconstructors
public and private attributes, just to name a few
All these principles seem pretty fair
Despite the simple philosophy though
many high profile programmers
Linus Torvald being one of them
have expressed frustrations with the language
C++ can't solve the problem of the
Ist das ein echter Tweet von ihm?
Oder ist das ein Fake-Tweet?
Weil wenn es ein echter Tweet ist
muss ich den grad mal kurz retweeten
Ich dachte auch, der ist nicht menschlich
Ich dachte, der ist auch nicht mehr auf Twitter
Wann hat er das angeblich geschrieben?
7. März 2013
Okay
Hat er gar nicht
Fake
Moment
Nee, hat er nicht
Gibt's überhaupt nicht
Das ist Fake-Tweet
Mal ganz davon abgesehen
Ja, nee
So, why all the hate?
Well, as the language's inventor has said
C makes it easy to
shoot yourself in the foot
C++ makes it harder, but
when you do, it blows your whole leg off
Why is that? With great power
comes great responsibility
While C++ does offer more features than
C does out of the box, this comes
with a much more complicated syntax
that is more difficult to decipher
Error messages like
cannot dereference non-pointer type in C
Ja
Fehlermeldungen
C++ Fehlermeldungen sind legendär schlecht
Templates können
extrem ausatmen
Templates sind das beste und schlechteste
Feature von C++ zugleich
Moment, was?
Nein, kein Subset
Ein Superset
wenn schon, C++ kann mehr
als C, aber auch C ist
kein reines Subset von C++ mehr
Es gibt Inkompatibilitäten
zwischen C und C++
Zum Beispiel kann ich euch
Ups
Kann ich euch zeigen, zum Beispiel
C struct
Initialization
Ja, das funktioniert
so in C++ nicht, das ist zum Beispiel
keine gültige
C++-Syntax
Das hier
Das ist zum Beispiel
keine gültige C++-Syntax
Obwohl es gültiges C ist
Nö
Es sei denn, man braucht es unbedingt
Also man möchte in
Unreal-Innereien rumwursten
Okay, man möchte
Microcontroller programmieren, Embedded-Sachen
wo es halt nur gescheite Sachen in C und C++
gibt, ja, okay
Für alles andere, nee, auf gar keinen Fall
C++ ist glaube ich so ziemlich die schlimmste Sprache
die es gibt
Also C++ ist, ich sag das immer gerne so
C++ ist die hässlichste Sprache
die nicht als hässliche Sprache
geplant ist, also Sprachen wie
Brainfuck oder Whitespace oder so
Die sind absichtlich so gemacht, dass sie scheiße zu
programmieren sind, C++ ist dafür gemacht
eigentlich
ganz gut zu sein, aber es ist trotzdem
kacke
Nein, es ist nicht
C++ ist eine absolute Schrottsprache
Nein, nein, nein, nein
Das ist schon mal ein Denkfehler
Der C-Code ist definitiv nicht simplified
mit C++
Es ist
eher so, dass es komplett
unnötig kompliziert wird
Ja, du kannst potenziell
Sachen kürzer, einfacher und
theoretisch auch
klarer und besser schreiben, ja
Das dumme ist nur, dass viele Sachen, die in C++
eingebaut sind, die es eigentlich
nicht gibt
Sachen, die in C++ eingebaut sind, die es
eigentlich einfacher machen sollten
halt kompletter
Abfuck ist
Zum Beispiel hat sich irgendjemand mal
die C++ DateTime
Arpys und sowas angeguckt
Ja
Da hast du dann so Sachen wie
Ah, hast du keine
Da hast du dann so Sachen C++
Convert
Duration to Milliseconds
Ja
Und da hast du dann solche
Da hast du dann solche, solche Dinger hier
Bäh
Ich mein, seriously
Guckt euch den Shit mal an
Alter
Alter, the fuck man
Ich will einfach nur Millisekunden
in Sekunden umwandeln
So schwer kann das doch nicht sein, aber in C++
ist das nicht so einfach
2.
Don't use C++ features just because
they're there or just because
Das ist ja auch Blödsinn
Das macht ja heute in C++ so auch keiner mehr
Du verwendest in C++ heute ja lieber
eine
Range Loop oder wie das heißt
Ja
Aber die Sonntags
allein auch schon wieder, oder?
Die Sonntags
auch schon wieder
Warum muss das alles so hässlich sein
in dieser Sprache, man
Ich mein, es ist immer noch besser
Es ist immer noch besser
als das, ja
Aber ich glaube, das ist auch kein großer
C++ Checker, der das Video gemacht hat
Ja
Die Rust Taskforce
darf natürlich nicht fehlen, ja
Naja, das Video war jetzt irgendwie
ein bisschen nichtssagend, oder?
Wow
Also ich bin der Meinung, die beste Einstiegs
Programmiersprache ist
Javascript
Wenn man nicht genau weiß, was man machen will, wenn man sich einfach
nur ein bisschen rantasten will, Javascript
Javascript, du brauchst nichts
außer einen Texteditor und einen Webbrowser, den du schon hast
Und
du kannst gleichermaßen
sogar was Grafisches machen
Ich mein, weil du ja noch CSS und HTML dabei hast
Was wo du siehst, was passiert
Also wenn mich jemand fragt
mit welcher Sprache soll ich anfangen
ohne dass die jetzt genaue
Vorstellung hat, was er
was er machen will, würde ich jedem
raten, fang mit Javascript an
Leute, die schon ein bisschen Ahnung
haben, beziehungsweise vielleicht
so eine grobe Vorstellung haben, was sie machen wollen
denen könnte man auch
empfehlen, fang mit sowas wie
Python oder
Go oder C Sharp an
Aber das wären tatsächlich, also
ja, diese
die vier Sachen würde ich
prinzipiell empfehlen
Standardmäßig Javascript
Aber
ja, das würde ich sagen, Python,
Go, Javascript, C Sharp
Meinetwegen Java, wenn es
unbedingt einer will, aber dann lieber Kotlin
anstatt Java, musst du ja nicht
machen, wenn du mit Javascript
anfängst, brauchst du einen Texteditor
und einen Browser, du brauchst
kein Webpack
und alles
kein
React
brauchst einfach nur einen Browser und Javascript
und mittlerweile ist plain Javascript
für kleine Sachen im Browser sogar
echt ganz erträglich
Ja, gut, das ist natürlich prinzipiell
immer ein guter Ratschlag, wenn es
was ganz Konkretes gibt, was man denn machen
will, dann sollte man sich auch die
Technologie raussuchen, die dafür
am besten geeignet ist, in dem Fall wäre es halt
Java und Kotlin gewesen, was damals wahrscheinlich
nicht gab. C Sharp macht aktuell
extrem viel Sinn, weil du damit alles abdecken
kannst, ja, das stimmt
das ist richtig
allerdings, ich mag
einiges davon nicht, ich mag
Maurit nicht und ich mag
Blazor nicht, was im Endeffekt heißt
Cross-Plattform
UI-Apps mit der offiziellen Lösung
würde ich mit C Sharp wahrscheinlich nicht erstellen,
dann würde ich mir lieber sowas wie Avalonia angucken
und Blazor für Webseiten finde
ich auch unsinnig
dementsprechend würde ich da auch weiterhin drauf
setzen, ASP.NET Core im Backend
mit C Sharp und JavaScript im Frontend
und
iOS und
Android-Anwendung, ehrlich
gesagt, keine Ahnung, mit was ich das machen
würde, hab ich noch nie gemacht, wahrscheinlich
mit Ionic oder irgendwie sowas
oder man kann bestimmt auch
mit Zwelt mittlerweile schon Native-Apps
bauen, mit ZweltKit
kann man mit ZweltKit, kann man da mit
Mobile-Apps bauen?
Zwelt Native, okay
Flutter
oder
Flutter, ja
also wenn ich, vielleicht würde ich auch
in Flutter bauen, Mobile-Apps
Flutter Flow
sagt mir gar nichts
Beautiful Modern
Apps, Incredibly,
nicht Blazingly Fast, das ist ja Rust
vorbehalten, Start for
das kostet Geld
das ist quasi in den Forms
sowas wie in den Windows Forms Designer
für Flutter
nur dass es halt nicht so altbacken und hässlich ist wie
Windows Forms, ja gut
es gab ja mal
sowas wie Blend, kennt noch jemand Blend?
Das war für WPF, hat halt richtig gesagt
Blend einfach, du kennst das
noch, oder? So, jetzt haben wir uns
die Wahrheit über C++ angeguckt
jetzt wissen wir nicht wirklich
mehr als vorher, oder?
Dieses Windows ist ein Linux
was ist es denn für eins?
FX Linux
den Scheiß gibt es noch und das benutzen
Leute, das ist diese
Linux Distro
ich glaube, die haben wir uns am Stream
noch nicht angeguckt, das ist diese Linux Distro
wo sie einfach ein
Windows 10
Theme genommen haben
und über einen KDE oder
was war es denn, ich glaube es war ein KDE
drüber gehauen haben
ja, das ist auch eklig
MAUI ist genauso abartig
das ist so ein Ding, wo ich nicht verstehe
was Microsoft da baut, ehrlich gesagt
auf der einen Seite
Cross-Plattform, auf der anderen Seite
verbuggt as fuck, aber Linux wird nicht supportet
ich verstehe es nicht
also, ganz ehrlich
ich bin der Meinung, Microsoft hätte
Xamarin einzustampfen
war ja ok
ja, wir haben sogar ein Video von dem offen hier
ähm
die hätten das einstampfen sollen
und sie hätten das machen sollen
in Richtung Flutter
beziehungsweise
Qt oder wie auch immer
welche UI-Frameworks auch immer
sie hätten ein neues
Cross-Plattform-UI-Framework
bauen sollen
und zwar eins, was nicht aufsetzt
auf
die Native-Control-Elementen
so wie das meines Wissens nach
MAUI immer noch macht und deswegen
sie Linux auch nicht gescheit auf die Reihe kriegen
sondern sie hätten das so machen sollen
wie Flutter oder
Qt oder
tja, im Endeffekt
irgendwo auch Elektron, weil es ein Browser ist
und zwar sie hätten
anfangen sollen, Low-Level
Integration für die jeweiligen
Betriebssysteme und die
ganzen Sachen selbst zeichnen
das ist aus meiner Sicht
auch der einzig sinnvolle
gangbare Weg
für Cross-Plattform-UI-Frameworks
also du hast ja
bei UI-Frameworks
Leute
ich meine damit sowas wo man hier so
Oberflächen baut
und es gibt ja durchaus auch Leute, die wollen, dass diese
Anwendung nicht nur unter Windows läuft, sondern unter Linux
und Mac und
iOS und Android auch, das heißt man braucht
irgendwas mit dem man halt diese Oberfläche baut
so
und da gibt es zwei grundsätzliche
Ansätze
und zwar der erste Ansatz ist
man baut ein Framework
über ein Native Framework
drüber, also sprich man baut so eine Art
Meta-Framework
also sprich man benutzt unter Windows
dann eben tja hier
WinUI, man benutzt
unter Linux GTK
man benutzt unter Mac
nicht Metal
sondern
Cocoa heißt das glaube ich oder
man benutzt
unter Android eben das
Material Design, Java
Zeug und sowas
so, das ist
ne
ach was auch immer, ihr wisst was ich
meine, also man baut ein Meta-Framework
und spricht quasi darüber
die
jeweiligen Native-UI-Technologien
an, das ist die eine Variante wie man sowas
bauen kann, das heißt im Endeffekt
man
legt quasi abstrakt
das UI fest und unter
jeder Plattform sieht es etwas
anders aus, aber dafür sieht es so aus wie es
unter der jeweiligen Plattform gedacht ist
weil es eben die Native-Steuerelemente
benutzt, also dieser Button sieht halt
hier unter Windows, Windows-Style aus und unter
Mac wird der Mac-Style aussehen und unter
iOS wird der iOS-Style aussehen
das ist ein Ansatz den man machen kann
und das ist der Ansatz den Microsoft
mit MAUI oder Xamarin früher verfolgt
der Nachteil davon
ist
oder Chatge, ich frage euch mal, wir wissen ja
dass der Chat immer Massive HiIQ ist
wo PrimeSub noch mehr HiIQ wird
was ist eurer Meinung nach
der Nachteil von so einem
Meta-Framework-Approach
also sprich, man
setzt auf die jeweilige Plattform-Technologie
zum rendern und rendert die Sachen nicht
selbst, also was ist der
große Nachteil davon
gehört zu Facebook, außer davon
dass alles was Meta
unter Windows immer scheiße aussieht, also
der hauptsächliche Nachteil
davon, es gibt zwei Nachteile
das erste ist
dass die App überall anders aussieht
Leistung nicht, die Leistung
ist sogar ganz gut, weil es hier jeweils
Native-Geschichte benutzt
ja
also das erste ist
schon mal, es sieht überall anders
aus, das heißt auch
wenn du eine Anwendung
bauen willst, die
eine gewisse
irgendwie eine gewisse
wie soll man sagen
Logik hat
dann bist du vielleicht, dann möchtest du
halt vielleicht, dass deine Buttons
exakt so angeordnet sind und
du möchtest vielleicht auch
dass das an der Stelle das Menü hat
auch wenn das für die jeweilige Plattform
vielleicht nicht der Weg ist, das zu machen
und du hast
eine Anwendung, die sieht unter allen drei Betriebssystemen
zwar Native aus, weil es die Native-Steuerelemente
benutzt, aber die sieht überall
anders aus, das mag schon mal nicht so
schön sein, aber vielleicht gewollt
so und jetzt kommt das größte Problem mit so einem
Meta-Framework-Ansatz
du bist in der Regel
auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner
beschränkt, also
gehen wir jetzt mal von einem Button aus
und sagen wir mal, der
Button unter Windows unterstützt
nur eine Schriftgröße
der Button unter
Mac unterstützt aber mehrere
Schriftgrößen und der Button unter Linux
kann rund sein
auch anstatt eckig
das heißt, was bleibt dir übrig
du musst den kleinsten gemeinsamen
Nenner benutzen, das heißt, nur eckige
Buttons, ich weiß, das ist jetzt
recht simpel
man kann das alles noch ein bisschen erweitern
vom Prinzip her ist es so, du musst den
kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner benutzen, also
sprich nur viereckige Buttons
und nur Buttons mit gleicher Schriftgröße
weil du sonst
das auf einer der Plattformen eben nicht richtig
darstellen könntest, ja ich weiß
es gibt da noch
es gibt da noch die Möglichkeit natürlich so
Native Erweiterungen zu machen, dass du
dann baust du dann wiederum einen If ein, so nach dem Motto
If, aber wenn wir unter Android sind
dann mache ich das und so, ja das geht
dann baust du aber quasi wieder für alle Plattformen
ein eigenes UI, was es
auch nicht schön macht
so, das ist der Ansatz, den
Microsoft mit Maui verfolgt, quasi
die Native Anwendung
also die Native Technologien
der jeweiligen Plattformen zu benutzen
das ist der Microsoft Ansatz für Maui
und sicherlich auch noch für
ein oder andere UI Frameworks
aus meiner Sicht ist das ein blöder Ansatz
aus den eben genannten
Gründen, besser ist es so
wie das Flutter macht, oder auch Qt
macht, und zwar
die suchen sich eine Low Level Technologie
raus, oder Low Level
Technologien raus, für die jeweiligen Plattformen
und erstellen ihr UI selbst, das heißt
die benutzen nicht Windows Buttons
unter Windows, Mac Buttons
unter Mac, oder GTK Buttons
unter Linux, IOS Buttons
unter IOS, sondern
die suchen sich eine Low Level Technologie raus, also
sowas wie DirectX oder
Direct2D unter Windows
oder Metal unter Mac
oder OpenGL
unter Linux, oder was auch immer
und malen dann die Steuerelemente selbst
und kümmern sich um alles selbst
das heißt, das UI sieht überall
gleich aus, so macht das Flutter nämlich
auch, so macht das Qt nämlich auch
die Plattform muss halt gut unterstützt sein
letztendlich, also gerade auf dem Desktop
ist Flutter auch noch ziemlicher Crap
aber für Mobile ist Flutter gut
und Qt macht das
auch so, die haben eine Low Level
Technologie, oder ehrlich gesagt
Qt, weiß ich's, die haben mehrere
die haben zum Beispiel
die Möglichkeit rein
GPU, CPU
technisch zu rendern, unter
anderen Plattformen und auch Hardware
beschleunigen und sowas, im Endeffekt ist es der
gleiche Ansatz wie das Unity oder
Unreal oder sowas auch machen
die nehmen eine
Low Level Render Technologie
und bauen dann ihren Kram
darauf auf, deswegen ist das ja auch
so einfach, in Anführungsstrichen, portierbar
auch
ich glaub Qt kann mehrere
Sachen
ich glaub die können sogar Vulkan mittlerweile
können Direct2D, die können aber auch
per CPU
Pixel malen und so, die haben mehrere
Sachen, was die können
das hat halt den Vorteil, wenn du es damit machst
dass deine Anwendung exakt, also
wenn ich, angenommen ich hätte in Qt
diesen Windows Calculator gebaut
oder in Flutter diesen Windows Calculator gebaut
oder in Avalonia
ist es glaub ich auch so, diesen Windows Calculator
gebaut, dann würde
diese Anwendung unter Mac und
Linux und Windows exakt gleich aussehen
und
das ist meistens das, was ich haben will
in Elektron übrigens auch
und das ist ja auch meistens das, was
ich haben will, das heißt ich finde den Ansatz
den Microsoft mit Maui
verfolgt, ist der falsche Ansatz für Cross-Platform
UI, ja das ist richtig
aber das stört in der heutigen Zeit doch gar nicht
mehr so richtig, ich mein in der heutigen
Zeit haben die Leute keine Probleme
für eine publische Anwendung, die in Text
anzeigt 500 MB RAM zu opfern, weil
es die Elektron Anwendung ist
und das ist schon
der schlimmste Offender
in dieser Richtung Elektron, alles
andere ist eigentlich nur besser
ja, also insofern
finde ich ist
der Ansatz von Maui kacke
genauso wie ich den Ansatz von
Blazer bei Microsoft blöd finde
also Blazer kleinseitig
weil die müssen C-Sharp im Browser
damit quasi, die müssen .NET im Browser machen
über WebAssembly und das ist halt
immer noch zu großer Download und
Performance-Technik auch
Abfuck versus
JavaScript
insofern bin ich
sowohl Blazer als auch Maui
weiß nicht warum Microsoft
diese Ansätze gewählt hat und
warum Microsoft da
so komische Dinger treibt
Blazer könnte in Zukunft noch was werden
wenn sie Native Compile
Target unterstützen
und für WebAssembly, vielleicht
ja, aber Maui glaube ich nicht
dass ich das jemals verwenden werde, dann lieber Avalonia
also Avalonia ist ein Cross-Plattform
UI-Framework für .NET
die machen das nach dem Ansatz wie ich
das eben erklärt habe
die malen ihre Steuerelemente
selbst und
da sieht man auch, guck mal, hier sieht man eine Anwendung unter
Mac, ok, die sind natürlich blöd
die haben nur, ah hier
hier sieht man Settings
hier sieht man eine Anwendung unter Windows, Anwendung unter Mac
die Anwendung sehen halt unter allen Plattformen gleich aus
Avalonia hat den richtigen Ansatz
so
ok, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben
dieses Windows ist ein Linux, ja
das ist diese Distribution, die ein Windows 10 Skin hat
guck mal hier, ein Windows 11
hä, aber wenn ich hier unten
zum Beispiel, ich muss mal die Lautstärke
guck mal hier, ein Windows 11
hä, aber wenn ich hier unten zum Beispiel
einen Edge-Browser starte, warum taucht da dann rechts
nochmal das gleiche Eigen auf
und wieso sieht der Taschenrechner so komisch aus
warum ist die Auflösung so kacke
und heißt Kalk, wie bei Linux
ja, weil
weil das kein Windows ist, sondern Linux
ja, übertreib halt
bzw. Windows FX heißt das
und ist eines der seltsamsten und auch
dreistesten Betriebssysteme, die ich kenne
ob das Teil was taugt oder ihr besser
die Finger davon lassen solltet, seht ihr in diesem Video
bleibt dran
oh, ist ganz schön geschwätzt der Gude
herzlich Willkommen
dieses Video wird gesponsert
von 3CX
wenn ich jetzt sagen würde
endlich mal kein 3003 Video
über KI, sondern
wir haben ja die letzten Monate uns
zugekleistert mit
AI-Videos, aber verständlich, weil die Videos
gingen halt einfach immer gut
bzw. mit Windows oder beiden
guckt euch das hier mal an, lasst euch das
mal auf der Zunge zergehen, wie
originalgetreu Windows 11 hier von
Linux FX nachgebildet ist
das Startmenü inklusive vorinstallierten
original Windows-Themes
man kann die Fenster sogar so wie bei Windows in den Ecken
und den Seiten einrasten lassen
wie beim echten Windows lässt die Windows-Taste
und Punkt das Emoji-Menü
aber da siehst du schon mal, das Emoji-Menü
sieht auch schon irgendwie verkehrt aus
und das auffälligste dürfte sein
äh
das auffälligste dürfte sein, dass das halt nicht
die Windows-Emojis sind
Mülleimer, das ist
bestimmt ne KDE, ja denke ich auch
ich mein, es sieht halt ein bisschen
von der Leiste her so aus, aber
könnte auch ein Gnome-Skill, aber wahrscheinlich ist es KDE
aber der hat doch schon gesagt
Kalk heißt er, dann ist es ein KDE
wobei man Kalk auch unter
einem Gnome laufen lassen kann
aber das sind schon mal die falschen Emojis, sind schon mal nicht
die Windows-Emojis, sondern
es sind die
das ist nicht WeMoji
das ist ähm
das andere, was ich früher verwendet habe
EmojiOne ist das
ja, EmojiOne
oh
Unicode ist das alles
das ist glaube ich
EmojiOne, oder ist es doch
Gmoji, könnte
auch
man kann sogar einfach Windows-Exe-Dateien
doppelklicken und die laufen dann auch
also meistens
das habe ich gebraucht unter Linux
dass ich endlich Exe-Dateien
doppelklicken kann
möglich macht die Wine-Schnittstelle
die sofort installiert ist, dass
die Dateien-Wine automatisch startet
ja, sogar der vermutlich nicht so häufig
verwendete Windows-Konsolenbefehl
WinVER funktioniert
guck mal hier
da hat sich aber einer richtig Mühe
gegeben, oder?
es hat aber keiner Batch oder so
nach Linux portiert dafür
das wird schon eine ganz normale
Bash oder ZSH
sein
ja, aber da bröckelt
ok, ich brauch noch kurz gucken
Linux, gibt es das?
gibt es eine Batch-Implementierung
für Linux?
ja, über Wine, aber ich dachte mir, irgendwelche verrückten Leute
haben das nachgebaut
aber so bescheuert war glücklicherweise noch keiner
der lag auch schon
zum Beispiel, weil da oben trotz deutscher Einstellung
auf Portugiesisch steht
Sobre o LinuxFX
das ist ein Hinweis auf den Ursprung
des ulkigen Windows-Linux
es ist nämlich das Produkt eines einzelnen
Entwicklers aus Brasilien
und das Linux-Konsolenprogramm
Screenfetch zeigt dann auch, was hier eigentlich läuft
warum hat er denn so schlechte Auflösung
für die Linux-Sachen, die er da einblendet
warum ist das so schlecht aufgelöst?
ok, jetzt ist auf einmal alles gut
mit der Desktop-Umgebung
KDE Plasma und einem
Windows-11-Icon-Theme
man muss Raphael Rachid aber wirklich lassen, dass er
einigen Aufwand getrieben hat, um das Ding
so aussehen zu lassen, wie Windows
sogar ein Klon des Cortana-Assistenten
gibt es, Helloa heißt er
funktioniert allerdings nur auf Englisch und ja
eher schlecht, generell muss man sagen
sobald man etwas genauer hinguckt
das muss ich mir nochmal angucken
wie Windows
sogar ein Klon des Cortana-Assistenten
gibt es, Helloa heißt er
funktioniert allerdings nur auf Englisch und
but why?
warum wird
warum wird der größte Müll
geklont?
ja Cortana war auch Müll, kein Wunder, dass der richtig
funktioniert als Cortana-Klon
das ist quasi ein Feature schon
und ja, eher schlecht
generell muss man sagen
sobald man etwas genauer hinguckt
fällt das Windows-Kartenhaus in sich zusammen
z.B. wenn man bei den Netzwerk-Verbindungen
auf Einrichten klickt, ja dann kommt halt
der KDE-Netzwerk-Einstellungs-Dialog
der nur an Windows
gewöhnte Leute vermutlich verwirren würde
ich hab keine Ahnung, warum man das
nachbaut, ich wüsste auch
nicht, warum man das benutzen sollte
also mir fällt ernsthaft nix ein
warum man das benutzen sollte
oder wer das benutzen sollte
selbst wenn du
langjährige Windows-User hast
so irgendwelche Rentner oder so, was weiß ich
die Oma, ja
die nur an Windows gewöhnt ist und du sagst
hey, die fängt sich immer
so viel Blödsinn ein und klickt jeden Anhang
in der E-Mail an, ich mach da mal ein Linux drauf
ich glaub
selbst die wird nicht glücklich damit
wenn das auf einmal so aussieht wie Windows
aber halt kein Windows ist
schöne Übersetzungsstil-Büten sind auch drin
mit Lager ist Storage
gemacht, da kann man sich die installierten Daten
treffen. Na immer noch besser als Weltraum, oder?
Egal, halt anschauen
generell ist das Teil nicht sonderlich
konsequent übersetzt, das ganze Startmenü
ist z.B. auch mit deutscher Systemsprache
auf Englisch. Ihr wisst ja, kein Weltraum
links vom Gerät. Englisch.
Generell lässt sich aber sagen, man kann mit dem
Ding arbeiten. Es sind viele typische
Windows-Programme vorinstalliert, wie z.B.
Teams, außerdem gibt es Shortcuts auf die
Online-Varianten von Office und Excel
die im Browser laufen, dafür braucht man
allerdings... Vor allem, da ist halt
wirklich Edge für Linux installiert
Es ist wahrscheinlich die einzige
Distribution, die es gibt
auf dieser Welt, die als Standard-Browser
mit Edge vorinstalliert kommt
...ist ein Microsoft-Account
Die Offline-Nutzung ist OnlyOffice
vorinstalliert, das ist auch sehr brauchbar
Dreisterweise haben die Linux-FX-Macher
übrigens über die Icons der originalen
Microsoft-Produkte... Oh, da gibt's Ärger
von Microsoft, wenn die das spitz kriegen
bzw. wenn die der Meinung sind, das
macht Probleme für ihr Geschäft. Das gibt Ärger
...geklaut und im Menü auch
OnlyOffice Excel geschrieben, statt
den echten Namen OnlyOffice-Tabellen-Editor
zu verwenden. Und ansonsten
kann man halt Linux-Software installieren, entweder
über Kommandozeile oder über den
Discover-App-Store. Ich hab testweise mal
Steam über Discover installiert und
klappte problemlos. Da laufen die Spiele halt
über die Proton-Schnittstelle, wie bei
anderen Linuxen, z.B. wie auf dem Steam-Deck
Das Stichwort ist allerdings, wie bei
anderen Linuxen, denn außer dem
Windows-11-Icon-Set und ein paar
nachgebauten Windows-Funktionen, kann man
alles, was man mit Linux-FX machen kann
auch halt mit echten Linuxen machen
wie Ubuntu, Mint, Vanilla OS
Ja, es macht halt
wirklich überhaupt keinen Sinn
Ich verstehe die Daseinsberechtigung nicht
Aber es muss ja irgendeine
Art und Weise von Daseinsberechtigung
geben, weil das gibt es schon
eine Weile und das geht auch nicht weg
Also
ob der das selber benutzt?
Der Entwickler?
S-Manjaro, Endeavor oder
Arch, by the way
Wie jetzt?
Warum wird die einzig wahre
Linux-Distribution nicht erwähnt?
Und da hat man einen deutlich besseren
Community-Support, einfach weil das von
viel mehr Menschen genutzt wird, als das
esoterische Linux
Endeavor ist Arch-based, ja das ist egal
Arch ist nur das Original, was zählt
Das ist dementsprechend
muss dann ein Bogen und das
Arch-Logo und er muss sagen, dass er selbstverständlich
auch, by the way, Arch benutzt
Linux-FX
Man muss auch schon sagen, dass einige Sachen echt dubios
Ich benutze übrigens auch Arch, by the way
Nur so
Da ist einmal der ziemlich dreiste
Cloud
von den ganzen
Microsoft-Grafiken, wie Icons
und Hintergrundbildern und da ist dann auch
die Frage, ob Microsoft womöglich rechtlich
irgendwann dagegen vorgehen wird. Der Entwickler ist
seit kurzem auch noch ein bisschen frecher geworden
und vermarktet Linux-FX parallel
als Windows-FX
Okay, der will wirklich verklagt werden
von Microsoft, oder?
Sekunde
Der will wirklich verklagt werden
von Microsoft, der Dude
Der hat Bock
Der hat richtig Bock, verklagt zu werden von Microsoft
Hast du dir Vanilla-OS?
Nee, was ist das?
Ubuntu-Base
Nee, nee, das lade ich nicht runter
Dieses Windows-Logo
und alles
Alter, der wartet doch nur drauf,
verklagt zu werden von Microsoft, oder?
Android-Support
Leider ist der Android-Support, auch wenn es blöd klingt
unter Linux, ziemlich mies
Also auch mit allen möglichen
Emulator-Sachen und so, da gibt es tatsächlich
bessere Android-Emulatoren für
Windows als für Linux
Mag man gar nicht glauben, ja, aber
35 Dollar
Die Professional-Variante
Serial-Key
Das ist ja wie unter Windows
Windows Movie Maker
Ist das jetzt
neuerdings Gnome-Based?
Das sieht fast aus wie diese
Oder ist das KDE?
Ich meine, er hat sich schon Mühe gegeben,
dass es aussieht wie Windows, aber
ich verstehe den Sinn davon nicht
Verify
Yourself
South Forge, wer benutzt denn das noch?
Guck mal, man kann den sogar anrufen
Interessieren tut es auch keinen
Keine Ahnung, was das wieder ist
Also, echt kein Plan,
warum das ein Ding ist
Gleicher Inhalt, anderer Name
Das hat mir der Entwickler
Raphael Rachid auf meine Nachfrage auch bestätigt
Er meinte, es gibt halt Leute
Wie wäre es denn mal mit einer gescheiten Quali von der Mail?
Ich meine, das kann doch wirklich keine Sau lesen
Oder liegt es an mir?
Liegt es an mir, dass das irgendwie
rumbackt oder
5 Minuten, ok, man macht es bei einem ordentlichen Browser
Nee, das ist einfach
so blurry
Ihnen gefällt Windows vom Namen her ästhetisch
besser, ok
2001 hat Microsoft auf jeden Fall schon mal
gegen einen ähnlichen Hersteller geklagt
Lindos hieß das Produkt
Da hatte Microsoft zwar nicht gewonnen
Gibt es das noch?
Lindos?
Linspire, formerly Lindos
Sieht auch aus wie eine Webseite von 1995
Sag mal
Wer macht diese Webseiten
immer, alter?
Keiner
Sogar ein Forum
Ich weiß nicht
Aber ich persönlich hätte jetzt nicht so Bock
auf einen Rechtsstreit mit einem der größten
Konzerne der Welt
LinuxFX, ein paar Sachen, die nicht so gerne
gesehen sind im Linux-Umfeld
Zum Beispiel eine kommerzielle Variante verkaufen
Die kostet bei LinuxFX
35 US-Dollar, die bringt dann unter anderem
Android-Support mit und
Active Directory, ja ok, da kann man drüber
diskutieren
Gleich zerfließt er
Das mit der kommerziellen
Nutzung ist
Wie heißt deine Erweiterung für den Dark Mode?
Würde ich aber mit Vorsicht genießen
Weil das macht manche Webseiten extrem
langsam und buggy
So gelang es den Sicherheitsforschern
von Kernal.eu
im letzten Jahr, die Datenbank mit den Bezahlusern
anzuzapfen, die unverschlüsselt auf den
Servern lag, inklusive Mail-Adresse,
IP-Adresse und Aktivierungsschlüssel
Wir würden deshalb wirklich davon abraten
die Bezahlversion zu nutzen
Ich würde davon abraten, das überhaupt
zu benutzen
Allgemein zeigt das Leak, dass der
LinuxFX-Entwickler nicht so wahnsinnig
viel von Sicherheitskonzepten hält
Oder man könnte auch sagen, das Ding wirkt
manchmal so ein bisschen huschi-fuschi
zusammengefrickelt und wer weiß
was sich darin noch für Lücken verstecken
Und deshalb bin ich jetzt auch vorsichtig mit einer Empfehlung
Für Power-User ist LinuxFX
eh ungeeignet, die nutzen entweder ein echtes
Linux oder ein echtes Windows
Sinn ergibt LinuxFX aber eventuell
für nicht so computeraffine Leute, die
hin und wieder mal eine Mail schreiben wollen oder
ein bisschen rumsurfen, aber auf deren Rechnern kein
Windows 11 läuft, bzw. ist sogar auch
für ältere Windowsse
Ich find's trotzdem, selbst für die Oma
nicht sinnvoll
Rechnern keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr gibt
Viele dieser nicht computeraffinen Leute sind ja bekanntlich
ein bisschen ängstlich, wenn ihr Computer nicht mehr
so gewohnt Windows-mäßig aussieht
Und mit LinuxFX besteht zumindest die Möglichkeit
dass sie gar nicht merken, dass sie ein Linux benutzen
Also das ist theoretisch
ein Anwendungsszenario
Nur will man wirklich so ein ziemlich unsupportedes
mit heißer Nadel gestricktes
Windows-Linux empfehlen?
Kann man da nicht besser eine etablierte Distribution
Arche, by the way
Also sowas wie Zorin OS
eventuell, das ist vom Look her auch sehr
von Windows und Mac OS inspiriert
Haben wir das schon mal ausprobiert? Ich gehe davon aus
dass mich das übertrieben aufregen wird
Brauch ich...
Mich regt so ziemlich alles an Linux UI auf
wenn es nicht i3 ist
...richtet sich an Nicht-Frickler, wirkt aber deutlich
seriöser als LinuxFX
Oder man nimmt gleich sowas wie Linux Mint und installiert
da dann so ein Umsourced-Theme
Aber warum?
Ich will doch kein Windows-Hintergrund haben
Okay, ich habe auch
einen Windows-Hintergrund, Leute
Aber das ist ja nur
Teil Windows-Hintergrund
...gelehnt ist, zum Beispiel das von
Boomerang-Projekt. Also das würde ich als
verantwortungsvoller Mensch eher empfehlen
Auch wenn es am Ende nicht ganz so
Windows-ig aussieht. Was meint ihr dazu?
Habt ihr Erfahrungen mit LinuxFX?
Nö, will ich auch gar nicht
Habt ihr schon mal so computeraffinen Windows-Menschen
gegen ihren Linux vorgesetzt habt?
Nee
Hat das geklappt?
Ja, doch, habe ich, tatsächlich
Aber das ist schon lange her
Ich hatte damals meine Mutter Ubuntu installiert
auf dem Rechner, als die noch
Desktop-Rechner benutzt hat
Heute benutzt sie nur noch Tablets
den ganzen Tag
Da den Ubuntu, ja
und damit ist die gut klargekommen
Oder wurde da dann viel gemeckert?
Könnt ihr mal ein Video über eine Linux-Distribution machen?
Über ZorinOS
oder Mint zum Beispiel?
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und gerne abonnieren
natürlich. Tschüss
Halt Stop, halt Stop, bevor ihr ausschaltet. Kennt ihr eigentlich Tapas?
Das ist ja neu
Ja, kennen wir nicht
Ich seh den Sinn von LinuxFX
nicht
Läuft das Wallpaper-Script eigentlich automatisch
oder musst du das jedes Mal starten beim Reboot?
Pass auf
Da ist es
Das wechselt auch alle 10 Minuten
Das setzt nicht nur einmal den
Das äh
Das setzt nicht nur einmal den Background
Das wechselt auch alle 10 Minuten
Das ist wichtig
Was ist denn das hier oben eigentlich?
Guck mal, die haben die Toolbox geändert
Die Jetbrain-Toolbox hat jetzt ein anderes Icon
Was man kaum noch erkennt
Guck mal
Das ist irgendwie
Nichts
Nichtsichtbar
Warum hatten das jetzt auf einmal so ein Kack-Icon?
Früher war das doch ganz gut
Man erkennt ja gar nichts
Arsch by the way
Vorhin haben wir geupdatet und ich glaube
Vorhin war auch das Icon-Theme
dabei
Ja, das haben wir die ganze Zeit schon
Naja
Ja, aber du siehst, das setzt automatisch
das Hintergrundbild in alle 10 Minuten
Das setzt alle 10 Minuten
automatisch einen neuen Hintergrund
dass du auch dann beispielsweise abends halt
Hintergrund kriegst oder tagsüber auch schon mal
ein anderes Bild
Linux hat der NVM-Werbelauf
Das ist richtig, ja
So sah das ursprünglich aus hier
War das noch das alte?
Wundert mich, dass das Icon
kaputt ist
Oh
Wait a minute
Jetzt hat er es gecheckt
Ich checke aber auch die Leute, die sagen
wie schwer es ist, einen Browser zu installieren
Das ist total easy
Und schneller als unter Ubuntu oder so
Das ist der gleiche Weg, ja
Nur in Ubuntu hast du dann einen komischen Snap am Laufen
mit Chrome drinnen
Und unter Arch hast du es halt direkt
ans Trinken erinnern
Excellent
Also einen Browser zu installieren ist wirklich kein Ding
Zum Beispiel, selbst wenn ich jetzt sage
Vivaldi will ich haben als Browser
Mache ich einfach so
Zack
Vivaldi install
Yes, fertig
Installiert
Starten, da ist er
Also easy, ja
Aber
Brauche ich ja nicht
Habe ich übrigens noch Snapshots, die ich wieder
löschen kann? Nope
Das ist total easy, keine Ahnung warum es
Also ich finde generell
Pacman bzw. der Package Manager
unter Arch ist der angenehmste von allen
Ja
Ist auch richtig pp-iger
Da gibt es unter Linux keine gescheite
Und wahrscheinlich auch
keine, die unter i3 ordentlich funktioniert
Wie geht das, dass du
Linux und Windows gleichzeitig nutzen kannst?
Das ist nur 4M
4M bei Workstation
Nur auf dem zweiten Desktop im Fullscreen
Das heißt, ich kann immer hin und her schalten
Hier habe ich noch einen freien Windows Desktop
Hier habe ich halt die Linux 4M im Fullscreen
Hier habe ich das andere Zeug
Darkreader
Hast du dir mal Codeberg aus Berlin angesehen?
Ich wollte gerade sagen
Das ist doch der neue
Das sind doch die, die hinter dem
Fork stehen eigentlich
Weil
Gitea irgendwas mit den Chinesen
jetzt zu tun hat oder so
War da nicht irgendwas
Da gab es doch ein bisschen Beef
Vor einem halben Jahr
Ne, habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt
Ich habe ein Gitea Lokal bei mir
Und das lasse ich auch erst mal
Ja, die haben doch
Gitea hat doch irgendwelche Services angeboten
China Dienstleister oder sowas
Ich krieg den
Beef nicht mehr
Krieg ich den mal zusammen
Was war dann mit China
Ja
Die haben eine Firma gegründet
Also es hat nichts erstmal direkt
Das Open Source Projekt gab es vorher schon
So und in Oktober 2022
Wurde Gitea Limited
Bei Luni Xiao
Gegründet
Um halt
Business Services
Anzubieten, Paid Services anzubieten
Für Gitea
So und das ist irgendwie eine China
Firma
Und daraufhin
Haben die
Gitea geforkt als
Forgio
Also ganz ehrlich
Die Benamung ist echt
Das kann niemand aussprechen
Aussprechen Forgio
Irgendwas Italienisches
Genau
Und jetzt benutzen die das
Da ist wieder was da wieder abgeht
Es gibt in Open Source Projekten
Ja öfters mal irgendwelchen Beef
Wo dann geforkt wird
Esperanto, ja da kannst du von ausgehen
Es spricht sich aus wie Italienisch
Ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich nah
Bei der Aussprache an italienischen Sachen
Du benutzt Asahi
Was ist das denn
Ah Linux für Mac
Alles klar
Äh
Genau ich hab Dual Boot
Aber mein Rechner ist einfach so schnell
Das ich jetzt Reboote
Und jetzt ist der Reboot schon fertig
Und Linux vollgeladen
Irgendwie muss sich halt der 5000€ Rechner auch mal lohnen
Guck, pass auf, Reboot
Windows, Reboot
Linux
Habe noch nie Linux genutzt
Hat das irgendwelche Vorteile oder Gründe für Home-User ohne
Ja zum Beispiel
Das du dir viel weniger Gedanken drüber machen musst
Wenn du mal Malware, Viren oder sonst was einfängst
Es hat aber nicht nur Vorteile
Ich hab dazu mal ein Video gemacht
Auf Youtube
Linux ist kein Ersatz
Für Windows
Ja
Es hat Vorteile
Es ist aber auch nicht mehr alles so möglich
Wie vorher, ja je nachdem was du machen willst
Also es ist kein
1 zu 1 Replacement für Windows
Was dann einfach nur nicht die Windows Probleme hat
Hyper
Hyper Multithreading ist das
Guck, Bam, Reboot
Du kannst dir Linux
Nicht einfach anschauen, du musst dir erstmal überlegen
Welche Linux Distribution du dir anschauen willst
Dann würde ich sagen, guck dir sowas wie
Linux Mint oder so an, das ist eigentlich ganz
Einsteiger, achso das Video, ja
Ist eigentlich ganz einsteigerfreundlich
Was hat man sonst noch hier, Lost Places
Europaturm
Was verdient eigentlich
Was haben wir da Neues, was haben wir da noch nicht geguckt
Alter warum ist mein Browser defekt
Anzeige ist raus
Einfach Brocken
Immer noch Brocken
Nice, gg
Nicht mal Brocken
Wow, wow, wow
Alter, was
Neue Kette tut gut
Warum spielt das jetzt einfach ab
Was haben wir denn hier
Was verdient ein Metzgermeister
Was verdient ein OP Assistent
Gehalt
Gehalt eines Geschäftsführers
Für Fahrrad reparieren
Ich glaube den letzten
Den wir geguckt haben, was
Der Flugbegleiter war der letzte den wir geguckt haben
Ich erkenne
Eine Gbate Message wenn ich sie sehe
Ja
Die sind meistens richtig krass am Arbeiten
Im Vergleich
Zu irgendwelchen
Bullshit Bürojobs
Ich krieg langsam echt Hunger
Wie Apple die EU
Austrickst
Die neue EU Regelung
Die fortan dafür sorgt
Das technische Geräte mit einem einheitlichen Ladestand
Ok, ok, gucken wir mal
Wie Apple das austrickst
Das letzte was ich von Apple mitbekommen habe ist
Dass du halt USB
USB-C hast
Aber irgendwie nur USB-C
USB-2
Nee, dass du nur laden kannst über USB-C
Und du den offiziellen
Apple Stecker weiterhin brauchst
Ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt wirklich so kommt
Da hat ausgestattet sein müssen
Und zwar USB-C
Nur einer weigert sich bis zur letzten Minute
Apple
Und es scheint als müsste die Presse
Apple wie kleinen Schulkindern nochmal genau erklären
Wie dusselig es eigentlich ist
Nö
Apple weiß das schon genau
Und Apple weiß auch genau warum es das nicht will
Es ist nicht so, dass Apple keine Ahnung davon hätte
Kann es vielleicht nicht festzuhalten
This charges the iPhone
This charges the Mac
And iPad
And various other products around the world
Ausnahmslos
Da sitzt er
Jedes iPhone
Jedes Airpods Modell
Oder das iPad der 9. Generation
Verfügung über Apples eigenen
Schau mal Brave Browser Ausbreit
Ja, aber sehe ich keinen Sinn drin
Ich hab die Tabs ja absichtlich so
Es gibt auch genug Plugins
Für Chrome und Firefox
Ich mag das, wenn ich so viele Tabs aufhab
Dass ich gar nicht mehr erkenne, welches Tab was ist
Und ja, genau so lädt man hier
Ein Apple Pencil
Und wer jetzt glaubt, dieses Theater hat ab 2024 ein Ende
Und ihr könnt jetzt endlich die ganzen USB-C Kabel nutzen
Die ihr eh schon in der Schublade liegen habt
Der könnte sich gegebenenfalls irren
Und vielleicht müsst ihr sogar
Neue USB-C Kabel kaufen
Alle Infos gibt es wie immer im Video
Und falls ihr noch nicht abonniert habt
Aber umgedreht werden Apple zertifizierte Kabel
An allen anderen USB-C Geräten gehen
Ja, ich weiß, dass man Gruppen bilden kann
Will ich aber nicht
Man kann auch die Dinger markieren hier
Und mehrere Tabs reloaden
Und so gleichzeitig
Oder auch saven
Für die nächste Session
Kann man alles machen
Ja, mit meinem RAM flexen kann ich auch
Guck hier, es muss sich ja irgendwie lohnen
Dass ich 64GB RAM hab
Könnt ihr das jetzt während des Intros tun
Viel Spaß
14.53 im Markt
Uff, im Grunde genommen sagt sie
Dass für folgende Geräte USB-C
Zur Pflicht wird
Smartphones, Tablets, Digitalkameras
Tragbare Spielekonsolen, Kopfhörer und Headsets
Lade-Etuis für In-Ears
Tragbare Lautsprecher
Tragbare Navigationssysteme
Tastaturen und Mäuse
Und ab 2026 Laptops
Auch Fast Charging wird vereinheitlicht
Mein Laptop hat schon USB-C
Und nicht nur USB-C Charging
Sondern sogar USB-C Display
Du kannst einfach Displays anschließen
Eigentlich ganz nice
Und so müssen Geräte mit
Schnellladefunktionen demnächst
Standard USB Power Delivery
Also USB-PD unterstützen
Zusätzlich gibt es neue Kennzeichnungen
Die Frage ist nur, welchen USB-Standard
Müssen die unterstützen
USB 4.x.gen
4.2
Mal 4
Oder was müssen die unterstützen
...die zur Pflicht werden
Demnächst müssen auf Verpackungen
Symbole aufgebracht sein
An denen wir erkennen können, ob ein
Netzteil inkludiert ist oder nicht
Und auch generell muss der Käufer die Chance haben
Ein Gerät, also z.B. ein iPhone
Mit einem Netzteil und ohne
Netzteil kaufen zu können
Ihr merkt schon, das könnte Apple eventuell nicht gefallen
Denn wenn ihnen eins heilig ist
Dann sind das ihre zertifizierten Kabel
Das Stichwort lautet MFI und das steht für
Netzteile gibt es ja schon mal nicht mehr
Weil Apple der Meinung ist, so nach dem Motto
Es hat doch eh schon jeder genug
Wir müssen bei einem 1.400 Euro Gerät kein Netzteil mehr liefern
Und das ist ja nur, weil wir umweltfreundlich sind
Ganz bestimmt Apple
Oder Made for iPad
Vielleicht habt ihr dieses Logo schon mal auf einer Verpackung
Für Kabel oder Apple Zubehör gesehen
Es bescheinigt dem jeweiligen Produkt, dass es
Apple zertifiziert ist und in jedem Fall
Problemlos mit eurem Apple-Device funktioniert
Damit Hersteller sich dieses Logo
Aber auf ihre Verpackung drucken dürfen
Ja außer Aliexpress-Verkäufer
Denen ist es egal
Die drucken sich das einfach selbst auf die Verpackung
Das machen sie seit 2005
Und forderten schon damals hohe Gebühren
Für iPod-Zubehör
Mittlerweile sind die Lizenzgebühren wohl deutlich gefallen
Dennoch generiert Apple mit dem MFI-Programm
Noch hohe Einnahmen
Und jetzt kommt Shrimp Apple Pro
Nein, das ist kein neues Garnelenrezept für Profis
Das ist ein Apple-Leaker
Der auch in der Vergangenheit schon sehr zuverlässig
Apple-Gerüchte bestätigen konnte
Oder eben nicht
Und der twittert jetzt folgendes
USB-C mit MFI wird passieren
Und direkt darunter schreibt er
Foxconn befindet sich bereits in der Massenproduktion
Doch was genau
Mich würde es auch wundern, dass es nicht so ist
Wer hätte jemand anderes
Vermutet
Ein MFI-zertifiziertes Kabel hat einen eigenen
Chip verbaut
Dadurch erkennt beispielsweise ein iPhone
Dass es sich um zertifiziertes Zubehör handelt
Was Apple nun vorhaben könnte
Zertifizierte Chips in USB-C-Kabeln
Um sie zu exklusiven Zubehör zu machen
Und um weiterhin daran mitverdienen zu können
Wer hätte das gedacht? Apple
Wenn Apple zum Beispiel schnellere Ladegeschwindigkeiten
In das Airpods-Case bringt
Dann lässt sich dieses eventuell nur noch mit Originalkabeln
Oder MFI-zertifizierten Kabeln
Das ist jetzt nichts neues
Da hätte ich auch mit gerechnet
Könnten eventuell für normale USB-C-Kabel
Zukünftig gedrosselt werden
Zwar gibt es auch jetzt schon spezielle USB-C-Kabel
Die gewisse Standards unterstützen
Allerdings sind die nicht herstellergebunden
Euer MacBook Pro also zukünftig mit 100W
Aufladen?
Vielleicht wird das nur mit Apples eigenen Kabeln möglich sein
Und eure bereits vorhandenen Kabel
Unterstützen eventuell auch nur noch einen geringeren
Datentransfer
Aber widerspricht das nicht eigentlich den EU-Vorgaben?
Nein, denn da geht es lediglich
Um einen einheitlichen USB-C-Anschluss
Eine denkbare Alternative
Zu MFI-USB-C-Kabeln könnte
Auch MagSafe sein
Denn einige Kritiker denken bereits laut darüber nach
Dass Apple den kabelgebundenen USB-C-Anschluss
Gänzlich verwerfen könnte
Und Produkte wie Airpods sich bald nur noch
Über Apples drahtlose Methode aufladen lassen
All das sind Spekulationen
Das möchte ich hier nochmal hervorheben
Allerdings stammen sie von einer bisher
Sehr zuverlässigen Quelle
Und zu erwähnen ist auch, dass Apple sich bereits
Kritisch zum neuen EU-Standard geäußert hat
Und beispielsweise damit argumentiert
Dass bereits vorhandene Lightning-Kabel
Ja nun auch zu unnötigem Kabelmüll werden
Äh, weiß ich nicht
Apple argumentiert immer ganz gerne
Mit Umweltschutz
Wenn das bedeutet, dass sie sich für Apple
Damit was rausschlagen lässt
Ansonsten juckt das Apple auch nicht wirklich
Außerdem sagt Apple
Das Einschreiten der EU sei Innovationshemd
Okay, aber betrachtet man jetzt mal
Ganz explizit Lightning
Hatte es Apple da in der Vergangenheit bisher auch nicht
So mit Innovationen und hat sogar eigene
Produkte reglementiert
Also wenn Apple in Bezug auf Kabel von Innovationen spricht
Schwierig
Wenn heute Apple ihr MFI-Programm aber tatsächlich
In Bezug auf USB-C durchziehen
Dann könnte, wenn ihr kein originales Kabel
Oder kein MFI-zertifiziertes Kabel benutzt
Demnächst sowas
Auf eurem iPhone angezeigt werden
Das ist kein offizielles
Alter, MonkaS
Wenn das so kommt, dann muss ich echt sagen
Wäre ich echt enttäuscht von Apple
Denn wenn sie eins auf ihren Keynotes oder anderen Marketing-Plattformen
Immer wieder unterstreichen
Dann wie umweltfreundlich der Konzern doch sei
Die EU will genau da ansetzen
Und es vermeiden, dass wir zukünftig
Keine zahlreichen Kabel mehr in unseren Schubladen bunkern
Und dass wir die Anzahl
Also im Prinzip ist es das, was uns
Im Vorfeld schon klar war, Apple lässt sich
Kabel zertifizieren, das wurde glaube ich schon
Das ist jetzt ja auch nicht mal irgendwie was
Sonderlich Neues
Also das wurde ja schon laut
Quasi seit der Ankündigung
Wir machen jetzt USB-C
Das ist nicht wirklich großartig
Was Neues jetzt
Hast du das Proxmox 8 schon angeschaut?
Ich hab's dann machen, hab's aber nicht mehr auf die Reihe gekriegt
Machen wir aber noch
Und wir probieren das dann auch mal mit einem Cluster
Und ob man da über Terraform was drauf installieren kann
Und sowas, weil ich hab ja keine wirklichen
Anwendungsszenarien für Proxmox bei mir lokal
Ja, mal gucken
Also wenn eins
Apple gut kann, dann ist es solche Sachen
Irgendwie
Mit 30 Milliarden Anwälten zu umschiffen
Dass man da irgendwelche Lücken findet
Nee, warum?
Warum nicht?
Juckt ihr nicht, nee
Leute, wisst ihr was ich jetzt essen geh?
Ich hab übelst Hunger
Ihr kommt nie drauf, was es heute zu essen gibt
Lachs mit Nudeln
Beziehungsweise Nudeln mit Lachs, korrekt
Das Übliche
Okay, Leute
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream
Macht's gut, bis dann
See you